two yeah
hello everybody hello it's a rainy day
out here in Los Angeles
and we've got of course my beautiful
co-host Ela Klein who's thank you who's
looking extra she looks so [__] extra
extra today thank you and of course the
lovely the hilarious Tana Mojo who hi
guys
very happy
that we are able to do this one-on-one
like this or two on one I never thought
like a year ago that I would be just
like driving to the H3 podcast alone
like a year ago I would have been like
trembling shaking crying crying no we're
besties you're a friend of the show
status I love this progress the story
arcs
beautiful well you know we did the um
the the steamies together I think that
was very gracious of you guys to comment
we had a good rapport we were having
good laughs we're having a good time so
it works is so nice to me I never want
to come on and be like your audience is
so great like trying to like you know
what I mean suck your audience's ass but
they were so nice and I definitely have
a respect for the type of audience that
you kind of have to like earn dude there
respect they could go our audience they
love you or they hate you but I was
the fact that they at least give you a
chance to love you or hate you there's a
lot of audiences where I would go on and
I know no matter what I say or do
they're either gonna [__] hate me or
like suck fart out of my ass and that's
cool [__] the far out of your ass yeah
no that's okay it was just awesome the
comments were so nice I was like beside
myself well because it was great it was
good content everyone was happy so I'm
glad we're here together
brought to you by
gamer stuff I need people on payroll to
just like [__] clap for me it's
actually in their contract bladder and
some sometimes after the show I go guys
bring up the decibels depressing that's
why Dan
goes crazy sometimes uh gamer sub guys
sponsored us today GG thank you to them
yeah
um
you know that's stylish today boy I
didn't know what to expect I don't know
if you would or not I should have it's
just so rainy in L.A and Friday for me
is like worse than Monday like I wake up
on a Friday just like oh my [__] god
did you drink yesterday no I'm um You're
Sober yeah right
um but I'm really just scheming here you
know what I mean I'm just trying to get
close to you you're the cool girl our
friend group has been like so obsessed
with you what really
um just we just we love a stylistic
[__] cool nice girl right here and um
today I called my best friend in the car
and I was like yeah I'm going to do H3
and he was like Eli hasn't followed me
back
okay I have no idea how do people know
when people follow them because like
there's so many notifications absolutely
absolutely I don't think he was actually
upset it's just like a running man
because sometimes actually like I'll
follow somebody and then they'll message
me like hey thanks for the following I'm
like how do you know how do you even
notice wait I never know wait you don't
know that because I'm always wondering
how do I wonder that two on Instagram
especially yeah on Twitter now that the
verified tab is screwed like I don't
know anything anymore but on Instagram
AB do you know how the people do that
you can like do you just read all their
verified users and like be a pretentious
[__] and like see only the verified
people that follow you which I love to
do oh I would do that I didn't even know
you could do that I'll show you I'll
show you yeah I don't care about plebs
following me but I was thinking when I
was
today I was thinking
like I kind of like dedicate this look
to you it's so good because I feel like
you've become like this boss
Boss Ass [__] business [__] and I
think this is like no this is that the
Glam it's so good I like gave my all to
the steamies I had like nine people like
self-tending my armpit and [__]
you know I just I can't I get it it's a
lot of work on this stuff 100 dude I I
this is me you know I don't climb up I
don't do I don't know what what someone
who carries the team on her back yeah I
mean as far as the looks I mean in
everything let's be real
so um
last one you were on
actually I want to ask you about your
diet you're doing what is it called
um 75 hard is that your own thing no
this is funny imagine it was I don't
know I'm not there yet
if I created a diet plan it would be
like smoke two blunts and then get a
Crunchwrap
um it's actually it's really common it's
a really common one
um for 75 days you basically just don't
drink you stick to any like Diet of your
choice so I've been like gluten free
Vibes
um you're supposed to work out twice is
that a diet gluten-free it could be I
guess yeah I mean I'm not sure that
counts as a diet really I mean if you're
good for me
and you lose a lot of weight yeah
so yeah you're not eating like
gluten-free bread I am oh yeah so but
like Ezekiel Bread it's made out of like
nuts and [__] you know what I feel that
Godly bread yeah it tastes like [__]
awful like a birthday card but you know
what I mean I'm I'm out here doing it
okay so we're so we're not doing uh like
a cauliflower buffalo wing instead of a
buffalo wing okay that type of [__] but
I wasn't really doing it for the food
aspect of it that was kind of like the
least one that I was like focused on you
know what I mean you're supposed to like
read like 10 20 pages of a book a day
you're supposed to journal yeah I made
this Tai Lopez absolutely
[__] Lamborghini it's behind a
paywall I saw one of the one of the
things was read 10 pages of non-fiction
I'm like yo what why that hate why why
yeah
fiction is good ask [__] AB the dude
reads Twilight every [__] night yeah
and look how how good smart he is
honestly that's really that's that's
valid I love a non-fiction book are you
reading nonfiction yeah I've been
reading 48 Laws of Power have you ever
read that it's honestly I can't figure
out if I think it's an awesome way to
think about life or if it's a horrible
mentality it's like what is the idea
premise of the book is like everyone in
life has their best intention like has
their like intentions for themselves so
like manipulate and like [__] you
like you know what I mean I don't I
don't know how I feel about it I could
tell from the title it was like
Machiavellian like how to be a
psychopath absolutely like I'm just
catching myself like gaslighting men for
no reason I'm like it's it's law 40.
okay so this diet so far is not it's
like you you're reading a book about how
to be a psychopath okay and all right
and so maybe just read like Harry Potter
yeah honestly absolutely you need to
catch up on my Voldemort but um so how
long how deep into it are you uh like 30
something days of 75. are you weighing
yourself
um not really I don't I I feel like you
get caught up when you're weighing
yourself I've never been a scale person
because it's like I'll get on it every
hour and be like you know what I mean
Have I Lost point one of a pound where
it's like well I did it in the morning
but do I do it in the evening I spiral
absolutely well sometimes I'll go a
whole week and I'm like this was the
best week ever yeah and I'm like the
same way and then I spiral and I say
[__] this exactly my point do you know
what I mean like it's just like I can't
let the number like I feel great you
know what I mean I feel so [__] happy
and motivated like that's why I did it I
just wanted to like be as mentally clear
and on it as possible and kind of just
Implement I guess structure and routine
um so if I was like yeah I can't okay
that's just a perk for me so have you
noticed better have you noticed any
changes in your body are you just
feeling good I guess maybe a little like
I've been doing a lot of cardio because
you have to work out like twice a day on
it which I'm not always doing yeah this
says complete two 45 minute workouts
that's a little intense yeah we're
hitting Tana's version the version I'll
be like an hour and 15 of cardio though
which is all almost good can I ask you
to do subtitles count as non-fiction
I mean reading is reading I like
watching impulsive with the subtitles
I'm like no
we gotta we gotta find a way to get
through this absolutely that's funny
yeah but now it just kind of like feels
normal and I feel good so nice good for
you it really just for me was like stop
being crazy Tana good love that for you
okay so I've loved that for you so we're
doing 75 hard
maybe 75 soft yes
okay good for you that's nice we're also
doing Fitness Journeys ELO's been uh
because we're getting ready to have our
third baby yeah we talked about I've
been exercising twice a week but I feel
like it's pretty hardcore what's the
prep for that like you're yeah
oh what's the prep so after this the
last pregnancy my back pain became like
impossible oh my God it just like was
awful I couldn't do anything and it was
becoming like part of my daily problems
even after you had the baby yeah oh my
yeah no I'm I'm going to the adoption
shelter and I'm picking out one like a
Starbucks frappuccino that's so
terrifying yes so I had to figure it out
yeah I was trying to think like maybe
there's something wrong with my back
yeah so I finally went to see a doctor
and he was like is it here and I'm like
yes yes here yes and he was like all of
this is just muscle so you just need to
exercise oh yeah my chiropractor was
just kind of teaching me that like I was
having a bunch of shoulder pain yeah do
shoulder workouts I was like okay you
just crack me I know it's not what I
wanted it was a chiropractor that told
you that no no it was a doctor I have
like a beef with chiropractors do you
I'm anti-chiropractor anti-chiral yeah I
think they're all I think the whole
field is quackery oh I tell I need more
I need more well okay so because I'm out
here like they changed me some of them
are really crazy like maybe you guys can
pull up some of the really crazy
chiropractor ones like from Russia where
they just [__] slam them oh and get
my favorite were they drown quarter the
guy
so some of them are like crazy right
like it's just another prolapse video
but I I don't think that like as far as
research and data shows the cracking
doesn't do anything
that's so interesting I mean I've never
like read up on my research and data
backtracking Maybe I'm placebo effect
because I leave like you feel good like
I'm I'm gonna run a marathon and how
long does that last [__] two days
it's like a massage yeah some people
need to feel pain to relieve the pain
yeah I mean I really don't know look
does he ever done anything we're like
this doesn't this doesn't doesn't feel
right I don't know I mean it hurts a lot
I've really about scoliosis so I go in I
do too yeah it's awful I look like
Hunchback of Notre Dame at like all
times for sure but um
I don't know it works it does for you
okay good I guess I I the exercise did
help you're doing my own back workouts
yeah all kinds like strengthening my um
ABS yeah because I had like nothing here
oh so that your core helps you like get
up yeah better wow I just bought a
posture corrector I feel like I'm 80.
it's like this weird little thing you
like stick on your back and then an app
notifies you everything and you like
don't and like you can just I think it
can like shock you a little like say a
little wave
by super gimmick it's giving uh
infomercial but we'll see yeah so I
actually lost like 20 pounds
I was getting very
meatballish I actually had a beef with
Philip DeFranco Reese or just did you
yeah he got mad that I said I S you know
I can't I said I pledge not to talk
about his weight anymore so I'm not
going to but he got mad at me I don't
even remember what he looks like
honestly like like I know I know what he
looks like he lost a lot of Weights like
I don't know what he looks like now yeah
he's looking good no he's looking good
and I think Ethan just thought that they
were kind of like he yelled at mutually
like joking yeah making poking fun at
each other but and then what did he say
yeah he did he did a uh one of his shows
and he goes oh and by the way this is a
total aside but Ethan Klein stop [__]
talking about my weight I can't even
imagine Franco like I didn't know why
irate you know yeah I was heartbroken
but so apparently yeah but but you know
I'm trying to do it too I'm trying to
lose weight what is he even report on
now I feel like the internet is so
non-drama like you know what I mean the
way at least the way it used to be he
does news I'm gonna look it up 25.
well so here this is the kind of
chiropractor that
I'm personally interested in
oh no why is it so boring it weirds me
out
that's cool not that one no well well
you haven't seen so much porn like that
where they like chained them up like
that in the room looks exactly the same
it's always the weird house
too do you watch BDSM stuff because I've
never seen a porn like that you've never
seen a porn like that I don't watch them
stuff tied up all fours okay it's just
not my cupboard I'm not like a BDS
you clearly know a lot more I know a lot
about a lot
all right well tell me if you ever seen
a porn like this I have
hold on you don't know where it's going
why is it so blurry I just know
someone's [__] is going to be
prolapsed in this yeah in two [__]
seconds
where's the sound all we're missing is
just like an ad on the right side like
singles near you okay here let's try
again
sorry here we go yeah you need the sound
us
well
three
[Music]
that's you know and that that's where
chiropractor is heading like that WWE
that's the that's the natural
progression you know what I mean what
point like what happened to this man for
him to be like this is what I need to
fix he's got back pain do you know what
I mean I got [__] back pains and they
just leave them up there too they leave
apparently and then they come back after
lunch
absolutely
he's just hang in there man so that so
you know what I mean this is the kind of
chiropractor that I that I yeah that
you're into they're in the same field
though they're in the same field it's
kind of crazy can you guys find the dude
who slams his Mallet into the people
yeah the Russians have a special
interest in chiropractor so anyway
um last time we were on by the way when
you came on with Jeff there was some
kind of tea that you didn't want to
speak on about Todd
I didn't forget I didn't forget you
a little bit of drunk I've never
forgetting oh my God that's insane I'm
like I'm like the elephant of drama I
was just gonna say that but I felt like
you would think it was like a weight
thing or something bro you could call me
fat I'm not sure
well I am fat and frankly now I know
you're lying to me oh my God I don't
think you're fine thank you and I also
think Dad bought is superior I know what
girls mean when they say Dad but no no
they're like they're like you're jacked
but like you don't know do you know how
many no no I mean I'll start that
sentence like that
um I've definitely been in a position
where it's like no like he can't see his
toes and I'm into it you know really for
sure okay hold on hold on let me get
your you guys and all the ladies who
want to chime in let me get your honest
take in terms of like what's a dad bod
okay okay so do you think this is a dad
bod no of course not that's not that's
not a dad bot okay that's not a dad bot
at all because that's what I think most
girls are like no it's a dad bod it's
like no he's [__] jacked
up are these dad bods what's wrong with
him dude is his lips all white what do
you even bro do you just eat a pack of
donuts like what the [__] crazy that
your mind goes to donuts and mine goes
to cocaine okay
and that's that's just our lives in
different spots
but why the [__] would you have cocaine
around his lips that's pretty wild isn't
it
absolutely I guess some people get crazy
I mean I guess you could say this is
like the the entry level dad bought
everybody's saying no even in the chat
they're saying no but okay okay that's
not what people think of when they say
yeah okay then let me pull this up like
do you consider this a dad bod like Seth
Rogen okay damn it like Seth Rogen Dad
yeah and you like that he looks amazing
okay
[__]
like oh my God I'm here for it Seth
Rogen call me
that's my guy right there Bonnie it's
just like no one
and this is It's been a fashionable too
generalization on my behalf but it's
just like I those guys are almost always
funnier than the ones the dad bod guys
Jim mirror picking all day and it's like
I'm just you know that's what I always I
kind of think that the guys with like
the full-on muscles like they don't even
do it for the girls it's like girls
don't I I don't care about it I think
it's almost to impress one another yeah
at the gym Chris Pratt is the only other
dude I've seen with nipples smaller than
mine that man has the smallest nipples
his tables are smaller than mine
we love that about you okay so again
still you know let me find like a real
dad bod like on this kind of like real
[__] gross
hold on
let's see and it's also you know what I
mean if they have a dad bottom they're
awful then obviously you know it's I'm
just a personality ground oh yeah I'm
just not like most girls why is it that
all of your boyfriends I've seen are
like super [__] like hot looking
what
I don't know like the guys they're all
hot to me I just want to say but like no
they're like they look like uh models
and [__] or at least that one guy I
guess baby
who's the ugliest guy you did
give me his name let's look it up
to climb the state how about this I
can't I lose the most bad bonded guy you
dated
that's
nothing okay
a little Zan yeah that's what I was
gonna say you were like you're all
generally hot I feel like well he he was
funny in the regard that like
no I'm not laughing with him but I I
things were funny you know what I mean
but that was a long time ago I'm
reformed he's funny like the way that
like you're performing you remember
something about Mary I'm sorry oh [__]
you know where I was going with that you
know he's funny in the way that
I think we had a little beef when I was
um dating him there was a period of time
where I was like living with him and we
were dating we were in a full-blown
relationship and he would be like
um my cousin's coming over and she's
gonna she's like cleaning the house she
works for me my cousins my assistant
months went by and then I found out that
she was just like his other girlfriend
also dating him at the same time
to be his cousin oh my god when you look
at that it's like oh my God what he
looks like in every picture no like look
there look there look at him with Noah
who I also dated how fun
um bisexual Queen
um he looks great there so tell me um so
is little Zanna is he always on Xanax is
that a real thing
um there were some periods of time where
the name fit the lifestyle for sure and
do you think um and now that was my
problem I just I and I'm still I'm
working on the full you know Reformation
but uh I love a love a drugged out
musician and do you think that the Zan
Annex affected his performance at all or
no have you ever taken Xanax yeah yeah a
lot of times many men and I'm not out
here like you know what I mean like be
prescribed you need to need it don't use
it recreationally it's very scary very
addictive yeah it is but [__] makes you
a freak you know Xanax you're sucking
chosen [__] because your hair you don't
care it's turning off The receptors I
just made me sleep weird I just wanted
to sleep yeah but if you fight that
you're eating ass
okay but again
you know what it looks like he ate your
ass and didn't brush
he probably just wasn't brushing either
way he ate the whole damn ass that photo
is a little scary for sure okay I hate
the the um
I hate the the Cheetos but what did I
expect come on I guess oh my god this is
my loyal Prince Charming I knew what I
was signing on for sure
um and again reformed I wouldn't what do
you mean by reformed I wouldn't do this
again I would not date change I'm a
changed woman what is it that [__] like
what is it about little Zen like that
you're attracted to like maybe famous
men or pop men who are like popping like
when he he's also like kind of like
problematic right like chaotic fun it's
a fun lifestyle for sure you know what I
mean and I just feel like again I don't
know like love bomber psycho you know
what I mean like a 10 000 roses at your
door but he's cheating but it's fun okay
I don't know I like that I get that but
I wouldn't um again this is a very long
time ago I want to say we dated like
five years ago
five years ago were even legal then I
was 19. oh [__] the screen we're like
the same age and so okay so that's a
little Zan now I I talked about
it I talked a lot about lausanne on the
show we you already pulled a gun at the
gas station that video I did see that
that was such an insane era the
paparazzi of him like yeah when he went
to the hospital for definitely something
probably very serious and then told all
of the press that he just like ate too
many Hot Cheetos oh yes yeah I was like
I really forgot about that oh my God
yeah good for him though that he
actually got that story out yeah that's
true so then if so okay I guess he might
be your most uh physically repulsive uh
X we didn't say that
but then you got these guys like
trust me you're you're making all the
girls jealous with this I remember him
Jay Alvarez oh my God that's so [__]
funny
I wouldn't say that was as
official and like whatever it was just
like a
it wasn't really dating yeah there was a
whole phenomenon on tick tock
I just saw like every comment or every
video was just like yo Jay Alvarez and I
didn't know anything about him yeah
really apparently or not apparently a
video leaked of him having sex with this
girl using coconut oil yeah and uh that
was all the rage yeah I recommend it it
was a fun time video but
um he hates when I talk about him though
I know this is going to piss him off
what's he gonna do about it send me a
[__] woke novel text sorry today oh
my God I'll just preemptively apologize
seriously but next time I'm in Hawaii
we'll stay our full view apart I promise
oh my god did he use the coconut oil on
you when you guys were throwing some
Barbados
he might have enlightened me to you know
okay you know but it's not like his
thing it's like he carries it around in
a jar in his pocket I'm not trying to
like you know but I also think knowing
him that he and this is an assumption or
this is a
so in my opinion that's that's what you
say do not get sued in my opinion I
think he um
leaked the tape himself oh yeah so
he was down for the world to know about
yeah his preferred fruit lubrication for
sure you know for sure yeah yeah
you also dated because you have such an
illustrious dating history I mean you
and Bella Thorne were yeah dating for a
while a long time you guys had a falling
out right we did we had a really really
messy awful breakup for sure and we
didn't talk for like two years we're
really cool now um
yeah everything about that was just so
Blurred Lines you know what I mean so
it's like when [__] like that happens
it's messy but
and Jake Paul of course oh yeah that
happened but were you guys really
together because you guys got you had
this whole marriage yeah good as mine
you don't even know I mean not like that
but I just mean like yeah your guess is
I mean I was in it I really cared about
him and you know
but oh man I can't speak for him are you
guys still close or do you we're not
close um we weren't cool for a really
long time and now I think we're cool
about a little chit chat here and there
um and we will like have a little chit
chat I guess but did you see that there
was an article in the New York Times
about him
sexually assaulting someone did you read
that are you talking about in um like
2020 yeah maybe yeah probably
um I remember that era I mean
that era and I'm like using [__]
Twitter terms for that like those are
the days
I remember that for sure that happening
and oh you you think it happened no no
no no no no no no no no no sorry when it
came out I don't think that happened
um I never want to be someone to
invalidate a victim in any regard of
anything but I was with him at all times
pretty much and I oh during that time I
don't and I don't from I I hate that you
it's wrong to say I don't think based on
someone's character they'd do that
because then people would be like well
yeah I mean the truth is the truth and I
stand with whatever and people hide
their ugly side anyway yeah I mean it
yeah I don't know did it ever go to
court I don't know um I don't know if
there was an update or I don't know if
it ever became a legal issue was just
kind of like a report from The New York
Times about yeah and I'm no
law dying on that Hill area
and so he can just it's his own Journey
okay I have my own Journey but you think
the best you think he didn't do it
it's okay if you have an opinion I mean
from what you can tell I I don't think I
would say I don't yeah I don't think I
want to say he didn't do it yeah you
can't say he didn't do it I don't think
he did it but I mean if he did do it
then obviously he should pay the
consequences and
it's really hard to like know someone so
well and like it I I don't know what
would you do if someone that you were
really really close to that's happening
like so many times in the past year like
three of my like close friends have all
been like had life destroying
controversies yeah Justin royland you
followed that one he looks creator of
Rick and Morty who's like
that was like one of the most brutal
cancellations I have ever seen from the
top he was like [__] buzzing and
that's something too if there's like
facts and things that like add up and he
did that [__] yeah like if someone did
that like there is so much imagine you
and hila are together for like two years
you're spending every day together you
think you really know her character yeah
like so on and so forth and you you guys
are throwing parties and there's a lot
of people with very questionable
intentions and making videos and stuff
like that like wouldn't
what would you do I would defend Ela of
course or I mean if if either was a cute
not even defending but I mean like do
you know what I mean just like
you know her you'd be like
I don't know you're saying you're saying
don't even just like def necessarily
like I would defend her at all costs no
matter what but if you were like I don't
think she did that yeah like I think
you're wrong to say that no no no I
think it's fair and especially you have
you have a more
you were together at the time so you
know
kind of who really knows you know I
don't know
okay so Jake Paul not guilty
Montana the judge every podcast one day
I'll it must be how like Selena Gomez
feels about like Justin Bieber like not
me I'm like Selena Gomez must feel just
like me that's not what I mean but I
just mean like when you have such a
public relationship Peak Fame thing with
someone yeah like you're always going to
be asked about it like I'm gonna be
married you don't want to talk about him
anymore
it's it's not there's no bad blood it's
just like you know we're not they're
close he lives in Puerto Rico he's
boxing and I'm doing my own thing and
then you know what I mean it's just
I I just like the girl in that era is a
very different girl I've grown so much
yeah I feel that yeah who's the guy
who's eating the burrito that cheated on
you what does that mean oh my God that's
so funny
um I dated this guy Brad he looks just
like Justin Bieber I'm like I dig up the
sky Brad that's the only reason why he
was just so awesome so he's beautiful
he's beautiful he's so so beautiful uh
it looks a little worse now now I'm
sorry yes yes yes [__] hold on give me
his Instagram
um Brad Susa I have a whole uh ass
Institute um and we're so cool now I
forgive him you know what I mean 100 I'm
honestly happy it happened did it
devastate you when it happened
yes and no being cheated on is never
here's all the pictures being cheated on
is never um fun I edited all my
Instagram captions after that Peter's
first Coachella so this is what I was
gonna show
it I never took him down this is why
Tana uh this is why people love Tana
[Laughter]
that's Justin Bieber
and I Justin Bieber's hottest man alive
and I really like his personality we had
a lot of fun together and he was great
to me and we were in a time at the end
where I wanted to break up with him
anyways and then
a bunch of crazy [__] happened we were
at Coachella I tried to break up with
him he wouldn't let me he ended up doing
a bunch of really crazy [__] that had
the police called and they put him on a
5150 hold they thought he was going to
kill himself and
um while he was you know away at the
loony bin in Coachella California he
left his phone I went through it he was
cheating on me he got back I said now
that you're that's a hell of a time to
look through someone's phone absolutely
I mean you were right but that's awesome
he's like in a padded room I'm like
who's he tweeting [__] yeah no
but I had a hunch anyways and but I will
say at the same time too like he went
from a normal Canadian boy and we ended
up bonding and we started dating like
the fame of it all you know what I mean
your Tana's boyfriend I want to [__] you
did it like all that I think is a lot as
like a kid to handle so
imagine like you just look like Justin
Bieber and like you're you're like he
was just kind of like a upgraded version
of like a really cute bag like I would
just take him around like there's my hot
Justin Bieber so here you edit the
caption says cheaters first Coachella
I'm debating deleting this but I look so
iconic and hot without a face tune so
I'd hate for that to go to waste yeah
yeah that's fair that's you know what I
mean why should you have to erase it
absolutely there was like ten I think I
have them all
looks dumb fat in this so I'm debating
delete that's it's not worth it to
duration keep it up you know what I mean
yeah I love that oh I was pissed here's
a pic of me on Valentine's Day at dinner
I paid for oh God was he broke
oh so broke and any money he was making
was like sorry for Vaping in your face
it's totally fine it's just like a
forced to have it to blow it away if
I've been around it any money he was
making was from like deals I was getting
him like do you know what I mean like I
cared about him I was like oh we're
gonna make you a star like you know what
I mean but
yeah and I'm happy that we broke up I
think that it changed the trajectory of
my life a lot and I probably would have
stayed with him a lot longer had that
not happened and I think he's in a good
place now well these are Vibes though
I paid for this dinner we took an Uber
that I paid for kissing someone who
cheated on me while he's wearing clothes
I got him exactly and gaining followers
from this pick wow you really took care
of this boy you sugar daddied him I used
to be so much more like now I just
wouldn't do that and it's like [__]
would you still do that pay for a guy
like in that absolutely not that's the
only time I've ever done that and it
taught me a lot is it just because he
was so hot I really liked him though we
had a lot of fun and
like he treated me amazing out of being
cheated on ever in my life that was the
only one that was kind of shocking to me
because I was like you kissed the ground
I walk on 24 hours a day you know what I
mean
do you wonder if he just saw you as like
a sugar mama like do you think he loved
you or you think he was just playing you
I have no idea to this day he will say I
loved you more than anything that's the
biggest mistake of my life blah blah
blah blah but like I don't [__] know
yeah and like yeah right like you're a
[__] Canadian boy out in the sticks
and now you're like in L.A living it up
yeah you you date different breeds of
men than people that I know yeah I have
no type it's very scary no type I've
never cheat I don't think I know anyone
that's cheated of my friends I don't
cheat we're all good boys around here
these guys are not cheaters and you guys
ever cheated raise your hand now I know
anyone who hasn't cheated see that's
what I'm saying we're in different
worlds yeah you cheated and I wouldn't
now I've only it was a very long time
ago but I mean so what does cheating
mean like a kiss holding hands flirting
or is it sex is cheating all of that's I
guess cheating right emotional cheating
I think so in my age yeah sure I think
all the way from emotional up is
cheating you know but yeah I agree I was
just kind of curious were you
yeah I mean I was just with a really bad
like abusive awful guy and I just didn't
want to break up with him so I was like
violently just cheating and like now
looking back okay but it was also a hard
situation I like would try to break up
with him and I couldn't and [__] so who
is that this was like my first boyfriend
ever before the fame
kind of yeah but like in the beginning
he was like here and there but I I've
laid him to rest he's like dead in my
mind he's dead he's dead [__] yeah
do you state um
like is it weird for you to date like
poor dudes does that ever happen
because it's just different like you
want to go do [__] and if he's like a
bro if he not even broke but like just
like a normal income it could be a
little weird where you end up paying for
him because you want to hang out with
him yeah it's I I dated someone for a
couple months last year that I met on
hinge okay
um and
but he's still up for me it's like if
you're poor and you have no job and
you're not grinding and you're not
making money that's where I would never
ever be with you like he was killing it
he was working hard and they're
and it's like if I can tell someone is
not in it for the money and I'm dating
them and they're working hard and they
have dreams and goals and they're driven
and whatever come on my jet who cares
right like you fly Jeff like not always
but I'm saying like I'll take him on
some some [__] if I know his intentions
are right but not even not what you mean
yes but like let's say he makes like 50
000 a year like normal guy yeah has a
normal job if I absolutely Head Over
Heels left him and I knew he was in it
for not the monetary reasons yeah then
you want to extend the things you have
with the people that you love you know
what I mean you like I've always been
that way I love that that's like why I
want to work and stuff I love well the
people I love there's The Stereotype of
like the rich guy with the gold diggers
you always hear that that term which I
hate I always thought it was so so
stupid but
from your experience because you're a
rich single woman
are you are you weary dating is it like
uh landmines out there do you think
dudes are gold digging
um
I I feel like now my just like read on
people I mean clearly as we just went in
this deep dive I've I've done it all
yeah like and and now it's just I I it's
just a read of character for me I'm not
really weary I just try to like you know
what I mean a couple red flags and I'm
out good like smart for sure so yeah I
know I know what you mean when you're
less experienced you get kind of just
caught up in [__] 100 and like new to
L.A and young and he's famous or he's
this or people love it they ship us that
none of them
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know um
thank you so much wow yeah we have a
five-star service that's what I'm saying
we don't [__] around sparkling or still
[__] incredible wait Lena she asked
for sparkling no no no no no no
[Applause]
but you you've been teasing a boyfriend
now yeah you just called me single and
I'm like well she's is not public who he
is
um it's not public who he is he doesn't
um well it isn't it isn't like People
magazine just posted a whole story with
his like full name and [__] and like
that people on Tick Tock are crazy
someone like doxed the [__] out of him I
posted one photo with him and they like
found where he lived put his address in
this ticket it was like going viral I
was like so pissed because it's like he
just doesn't want that you know what I
mean like
it's new still I'm just saying he like
he doesn't have Tick Tock download he
doesn't use Instagram he doesn't like
he's a private citizen very he's a very
very private citizen and that's where
it's like you start to feel that like
guilt almost I guess where it's like I
don't want you to have to be subject to
all this [__] you hate of people
tracking you down and yeah I can imagine
that's pretty crazy for someone who's
not from our world and someone who
doesn't want it because it's one thing
there are the people who are like oh my
God this is so cool I want Cloud blah
blah blah but like you know what I mean
it's just like [__] how did you guys
meet
he is best friends with my best friend
like childhood best friends with my
husband natural means yeah how people
meet people yeah and there was just one
day where I was like oh I really like
you like type of vibe and we both were
just like we're not gonna be friends
like this isn't we're not giving
friendship here
um well good for you I'm happy for you
yeah it's it's interesting he lives in
Vegas where I'm from oh wow you guys are
he's from Vegas I'm from Vegas I know
but he lives in Vegas yeah but not like
he's got to be a pain in the butt he's
very successful
um which is good but um
I'm still I mean you can take the girl
out of the out of Vegas but you can't
take the Vegas out of the garage I bond
with the Vegas guy like we are our core
values are [__] up but the same
um there is such a long distance is hard
it's really hard yeah is he well does he
want to move to L.A no oh that sucks
yeah and like how much do I really why
would he want to stay in in Vegas no
offense I know you grew up there yeah my
parents lived there my grandparents
lived there I've been there a lot the
fact that this man wants to stay in
Vegas is a red flag I but the thing is
is I was like that for a while I moved
out of Vegas when I was like 15 so like
nine years ago and for a while I was
like [__] that [__] that City for
whatever blah blah but I I kind of came
around to it again like I love it again
and I see why people who are really
success like he's in like real estate
you know what I mean so he's like very
successful in Vegas like if you if
you're living lavish as [__] Vegas
the cost of living is great there you
get the vibe of a big city but it's not
too much like weather's pretty nice
except for when it's really cold or
really hot like yeah Vegas people are
just very [__] real tell you how it
is like Vibes there there are
there are some perks to living in this
it's such a weird place man because it's
like you're on Mars it's like in the
middle of [__] nowhere and that's why
I'm like innately like a [__] from Mars
you know okay but it's like yeah it's
like the most transient City it's like
it's insane for sure yeah raising kids
there is crazy to me like I always I
just I remember growing up being like 14
like why the [__] would my parents
choose to raise me here you know
especially because we were poor I was
like of all cities like raising a kid
poor in Vegas is very scary you know
what I mean because they're gonna it's a
city of just drugs and alcohol it's
[__] up it's crazy Dirty Money like
you know and it's so easy to get like
caught up in that you know so what was
your growing up there like I mean were
you uh were you a uh hooligan growing up
absolutely yeah to the fullest extent
that's like why I started YouTube doing
story times about the [__] I was getting
into and making right
um
absolutely you're just like 21 by the
time you're like 13 14 you're partying
in the hotels and the casinos and you
know what I mean everyone's selling
drugs doing drugs so what do you what
did your parents do for a living when
did you guys move there
um they lived there for like 20 years
before me okay
um and they were like older like a lot
older
um your parents are older yeah are you
only child yes okay interesting um but
they're not
like my best friend's family like
basically adopted me when I was like 13.
like it took me and like now every
holiday I go see them they're my family
100 but like my family I was born into
they were they were just very crazy they
I mean all their money was very elite
not I it's so hard I I can't say a lot
of things for legal reasons there's like
a whole with your parents
which is nuts
um well so how long did you live with
your parents
I mean I guess technically until I was
like 15 but like by 14 I was like
staying with my friends for like months
at a time and [__] like I was I was out
it was just a very volatile environment
and
so growing up with your parents they
were
like what what do they have like some
kind of like what what was it how old
how much older are they
um
my parents were like in their 50s
Raising Me Okay um and they just in my
opinion weren't very good people like we
just you know what I mean we just they
weren't I was very independent like I
did everything on my own for as long as
I can remember it like it just even my
meals and my money and getting to school
and doing anything that's one of the
main reasons I dropped out of school
like it was just like nothing was a
functioning routine and I never learned
that I was very much so independent
anytime I really needed to fall on a
parental figure for anything it was
always my best friend's family that's
got to be thankful though that like your
relationship with your parents 100
that's hard that's really and obviously
being an only child through that as well
and not really having someone to like
and that's why I accredit my best friend
to like saving my life for like being my
brother he still lives with me to this
day like he's literally my brother and
it's amazing I credit him to really
helping me with that and I've tried to
work out there's so much trauma and so
many things that I can't wait to talk
about one day
um Jeanette McCurdy wrote that book that
was like I'm glad my mom died yeah is it
like that 100 holy [__] dude like I
can't wait until but you want your
parents to die
I don't want them to die I don't want
anyone would you be sad if they died
it's weird I just had this recently like
I guess I found out through the
grapevine that my mom was like super
sick I guess right my birth mom and uh
you don't talk to him at all you don't
have anything and even then it was like
it was up in the air of like what if she
dies right and I have this whole
existential moment of like
would that like I remember crying and I
was like why am I crying like I don't
feel like this person ever loved me and
I but it's sad knowing that it's closed
I guess you'll always have that
irrational hope that they could one day
be people and like apology it's not even
irrational we need we need the love of
our well I just mean situationally
irrational I know they know yeah yeah
um yeah and I was like why you know what
I mean and I I went to therapy about it
a lot my therapist was like
and it's hard to when you talk to people
about it because it's very much like
what if my mom does everyone's like call
her call her talk to her that's your mom
that's your mom and I've always been
such a firm believer and like because
people have said that to me my whole
life and you know I'm like I don't talk
to my parents I they're I they're not my
cup of tea and people like put that it's
your mom it's your dad but to me it's if
somebody shows you the love when you say
it wasn't my cup of tea I don't think
people understand I know because it
sounds like they're being in my legal
terms it sounds like there was abuse
absolutely it sounds like it was a
really traumatic absolutely you know but
so I've said that before and then I've
been in court having to almost pay
millions of dollars wow slander really
um you can slander your parents
apparently like what damage are you
gonna do to them yeah I so are you going
through litigation right now with your
parents this one it's over this was like
two three years ago did you guys settle
yeah because it's basically I guess I
can talk about this I don't know I mean
mean what did you sign at NDA
I signed a non-disparagement
so don't don't disparage them that means
you can be honest yeah yeah
um I received a letter you know that
basically said you said these things on
this reality show you know when I was on
MTV and I had a show we went and kind of
toured my childhood homes and I said a
lot of things that someone
in court could say you know create a
loss of income or which is so untrue it
was definitely just a money a cash grab
everyone was very in my opinion
um but everyone was very aware of it
being like that and it went back and
forth for a while and then it got to the
point where it would have been and this
was Peak covid so it was all over the
zoom and
just awful for my mental state as well
like having to just like relive so much
stuff all the time that to me I felt
like I had been beginning to put to rest
and
um
it got to a point where it would have
been years in court and it would have
been a public trial and it would have
been like medical subpoenas medical
subpoenas all the time and just like so
much you couldn't you couldn't get rid
of it on like before trial uh-uh well I
tried as hard as I possible
um and and I just I don't want to see
them I don't ever again I don't want to
talk to them ever again I don't want to
feel that way ever again I don't want to
watch them defend that
all the [__] that they did to me was
that they were good parents just
watching p in my opinion lie and um
yeah we settled and I had to pay them
like a couple hundred thousand dollars
wow that felt like [__] oh my God that
was like the day in my head where they
really like they were dead to me you
know what I mean because if you can do
that to your kid I'm mind blown yeah you
suck but I'm
words can't express how grateful I am
for my best friend's family like they
they are literally my mother and my
father and he has siblings they're my
brother my sister and I'm lucky as [__]
because you know what I mean I guess so
many people don't go through Tana Mojo's
life where you have a reality show and
your parents too which was a very I
would say that is a very very very very
rare upbring game 100 subscribing like
that's that's wild
um do you find it odd that like there's
two people they apparently love each
other or they're still together right
they're not divorced look I mean it was
the most
toxic thing they were not like a happy
married couple at all so it was just all
bad Loveless house but it 100 but I
think that um
trauma bonds are very real you know what
I mean so I I
don't know
I really don't I don't know I I couldn't
tell you what they're doing where
they're at anything like that probably
spending my money probably at the casino
what was it that you said that that they
suit that that they took issue with
um without saying it's true it's saying
this is what I like because the way that
that type of lawsuit Works especially
because you can do it two ways you can
pay a lawyer a lump sum or pay a lawyer
hourly or pay a lawyer retain them to go
do it or you can pay a lawyer a
percentage of if you win yeah and those
are that's what they had you know what I
mean that type of lawyer and that's
scarier too because then the lawyer is
like hungry to because if they don't win
they don't win any money you know what I
mean absolutely so it's just a thousand
anecdotal sentences like oh there were
roaches just a bunch of [__] or oh I
remember like you know what I mean
hypothetically I could have said
something like oh
I didn't eat for a week growing up like
there were there was no food or there
was roaches in the house or so they just
itemized all this itemized everything
and then I just had to sit in court and
sit there and go through every single
sentence and wow defend it as hard as I
can like I never I was talking about how
when I got to La one of the first things
I spent money on was an immense amount
of dental work and then because I never
really yeah had Dental Care
you can't say it you can't say it
yeah yeah but you can say you got a
bunch of dental work and we can infer
what that means yeah
everything it was
good yeah but and you had to sit through
that and they would sit there too on
Zoom a lot of it luckily thankfully was
mediation based where I would say
something to a mediator and the mediator
would go say it to them and then they
would say something in the mediator and
the mediator would come back and say it
which honestly I think really saved my
mental health a lot because I think that
if I had to yeah you know what I mean it
just it would have been a lot harder it
was crazy I just hired my
um what would be my executive assistant
for the next like three years and her
first like real thing with me like now
it's like come help me with Dizzy but
with with her it was like let's go to
court every day and I need you to take
notes and it was nuts that's how I knew
she was a great person and road for me
because it was very intense but yeah
shout out she's here Kyla no that's pink
but that's pretty incredible that you uh
survived that that sounds really really
[__] yeah I'll definitely have to
unpack a lot of trauma but in my life
but you know what I mean I I got a lot
of therapy about it and the therapist
was very helped me work through the fact
that like why do I want to give peace to
people who never gave me peace type of
thing you want to give peace to them no
like if they were dying like I would
only be doing I would only be saying
like goodbye for them would you do that
if they were like on their deathbed
would you say anything no what if they
call what if you're whatever but if they
called you or they're like hey I'm dying
I just wanted I wouldn't answer really I
mean well I don't answer on known
callers and I wouldn't answer if it was
their number I guess and I mean I guess
if somehow an interaction happened when
we were on the phone they said that I
would I mean I would probably just
respawn like a human being like I'm
really sorry that's happening and
damn you were in a better place in the
last quarter uh
got any [__] you can sell to give me my
money back well you know you know uh you
can't defame dead people just saying
that's trust me I I think about that
once they
um expire yeah that actually I want I
want to write a book so bad I've written
so much about all the [__] I've done in
LA but to me it Feels So incomplete
without that's huge a childhood story so
it's that's honestly the only reason I
don't have
uh
serious but life story up until now out
I guess
yeah me too like we're parents now and I
just I can't even imagine that's what's
exciting for me though I will say one of
the things like peace and happiness is
one day I can't wait to be a mother who
loves their children yeah so much your
way absolutely and you know what I mean
and maybe that was the purpose of all of
it I don't know I'll never know
so anyways guys that's so sad it's so
sad and I feel like I think it tells
it's it's very I mean this is a huge
part of who you are and I think it's why
it really is it's so crazy it explains a
lot yeah exactly I'm just kidding well
no but how could you not be crazy like
and do crazy stuff it's like my first
manager I really accredited to teaching
me a lot of so much just [__] I social
[__] I never learned like how to you
know what I mean I accredit so many of
my OG scandals to me just being like a
lawless [__] fatherless rat you know
like I needed to learn a lot did you was
there one parent that you had a bigger
issue with or were they both kind of
equally horrible
equally horrible in different ways wow I
think you know what I mean
yeah damn
Ed by your own parent I feel like it's
like a stab in the heart like what the
hell we weren't in a good place you know
when it happened I guess but I didn't
that's that's just such a further thing
you know yes
it's so hot I hate having to talk about
because you know me I'm so that's the
only time I can't talk about [__] the
way I want to is when there's legality
and it drives me and that's what sucks
you're feeling silenced about it for
sure but like
um
I don't even know like they always
in my opinion I think that my financial
success excited them there were a lot of
musicians where I was paying for things
you know what I mean for them by force I
I my 18th birthday was the happiest day
of my life because I've been doing this
for like three years and they were con
you know I was a minor they were
controlling my finances really they were
collected like if you got a check from
YouTube they would take it
or like not give you oh my god really I
had access to it I mean yeah it's you
have to be emancipated legally at least
in the state of Nevada I guess that
makes sense I mean you're under 18.
usually parents aren't that horrible to
do that um 100
um oh my God and I was so bitter for
years seeing the people with the Like
Loving momager who like helps oh my God
but um
yeah in Nevada you have to be to you
have to be like legally emancipated and
usually an emancipation requires a sign
off of the parents but what parent who
wants the benefits of yeah are gonna you
know and then obviously there's other
ways around that but they were just so
difficult
um had you looked into the legal options
of like separating from your parents it
was that bad oh my God I remember being
14 like knowing what emancipation meant
you know what I mean like I was oh yeah
and so that I find that interesting so
at what age were you starting to make
money based on your
your career probably 16 17. and were you
making like a good amount of money back
then that was like yeah I mean I
remember my first AdSense check was like
I remember it was like five thousand
dollars wow that's life changing yeah
absolutely especially if you're 16. and
I'd been dropped out of school for a
couple years it didn't seem like anyone
cared about my future and I was working
a minimum wage job what were you doing
um I worked at I did retail a bunch of
different retail like yeah and different
stores like that yeah
um and in my head it was like I will I'm
gonna have to work my way up here and
save money if I ever wanted a future in
an education and or I'm gonna go be a
stripper because I live in Vegas like
you know what I mean it's just like [__]
what do you do were you able to save
money
um yeah you were able to keep some of
the money for yourself yeah and I don't
think it was
I wasn't just never I never noticed like
say anything
um because God I would hate to be back
in court but um
yeah the [__] was just getting bought a
lot a lot a lot a lot by you know what I
mean and I'd moved out at one point like
by 16 or 17 I
um
it's I don't know if I can say all of
this I really don't I really I I don't
think it's in my best interest to tell
the story illegally do people know all
this stuff is this something you've
talked about like with your background
actually the most in-depth I've talked
about it people do because I feel like
it's
so important to who you are that 100 and
that's that was my a real battle with it
like and it still is emotionally for me
I would love to be able to just tell my
[__]
and I thought I was until I you know
received that [__] like I thought I was
able to what's the consequence of doing
that I wonder like if you consulted with
an attorney we're like I just want to
say everything like what happens what's
another lawsuit another lawsuit if if
that's their Journey how can they win
that lawsuit though or you don't even go
through that you don't want to go I
don't want to go through it I really
really well it's a lot of money and like
it's time emotional yeah yeah yeah it's
just terrible I remember thinking at one
point you know like the lawyer again
their lawyer was so hungry because it
was based on that and the things the
lawyer would just come and say like are
you sure you want to be in court because
I'm gonna we're gonna pitch it like this
this and this you're gonna drag it out
yeah you're a drugged out Hollywood
awful piece of [__] who doesn't love it
yeah too sweet oh yeah right
um too sweet elderly parents who just
loved you so much and were the best like
it scares you yeah that's not how the
world works is a court going to side
with the zero percent chance but it's
the it's the emotional battle yeah but I
mean for a while I think in that time I
really believed like what if people
didn't believe me you know which is like
scary I guess yeah
um that's really one of the most [__]
up things I've heard
three unlocked yeah
I promise you it
would I'm fine you don't have to 51.50
me at Coachella
um no I think actually considering all
of that I'm really impressed that you've
managed all this yeah I thought you were
just the best because I just thought you
were a mess but now I see that there's a
whole explanation yeah absolutely and
that makes me appreciate it clean up the
mess all these years but uh we'll get
there I guess I I'm not like you know
who I am I don't [__] care of people
like me or don't one day I'll be able to
tell my whole life story and maybe I'll
win some people back but I can't wait to
read it thank you it's going to be you
know it's what there's like a special
poison in that where it's like they they
put you through this and then they don't
even let you have the story that's what
sucks that's what sucks well I think
some people are often
narcissistic with abuse and they don't
even want to believe
that they are they don't believe that
they are yeah denial and it's and that's
all I ever wanted my whole life you know
just like hey I'm sorry we but that's
never you know because some people can't
come to terms yes
is that the fantasy that one day they
just apologize and like now they're like
we were right you were right and we were
wrong no no now because I've healed from
that regard I guess I'm not looking for
it it wouldn't
like now I just look cool you know like
when I was younger absolutely and you
always wish it was different but I'm
also not
upset with the the hand that I've been
dealt and and I was just home and my man
and I went and visited my family and
they were they're just so sweet and we
were it was like so
like Amari like my best friend's family
it was awesome like you know it's it's
normal to me now and I love it and I
love them so thank God for that eh yeah
we're good people out there
all right I gotta I'm gonna thank a
sponsor we just have one sponsor and
then I want to get right back to where
we left off
it's really fast it's a gamer so you
want to go to the bathroom or something
look at this yeah I'm just saying if you
want to oh no I'm chilling cool Gamers
suck
brought to you by child abuse
[Laughter]
perfect Segway every time but see I love
that I that you're just my kind of
people whenever people thank you I
appreciate it I think why I'm dark we
definitely have a similar sense of humor
coping mechanism absolutely so uh anyway
gamer sup we love gamer sup guys
gamer sub has a mobile app and all drops
will be accessible 20 minutes early
through the app so what flavors cups
[Laughter]
you want some Gamers up
yeah
you like that we use phillydeep for the
ad because he starts all his videos with
sup beautiful bathrooms oh I forgot
about that
I'll never forget hearing that on like
the day of tanacon and I was just like
oh yeah
guy
so let's see get let's get the app guys
20 minutes early download the mobile app
and get early access to the waifu cup so
that's important because they always
sell out on the site quickly tastes
great
I always hit the black cherry this to me
is a work of art and I love gamer stuff
because
not sugary but it tastes great it's got
caffeine it's the perfect
jolt in the morning it hydrates you it's
got caffeine you know sometimes I don't
want to have a coffee
right that's fair you know
it's fair yeah you guys I'm reaching out
to them I can't wait to be sponsored by
them can I talk about this back
conversation you want to do it after the
end
Gamers up code H3 they're cool they
won't mind they're cool we love them
yeah guys please support Gamers up
because I mentioned child abuse during
the ad read
they have nothing to do they're
sponsoring you that's like they know you
might as well be reading scripture you
know
yeah right yeah
anyway tastes great name of favorite
flavor which is black cherry there's no
sugar
it doesn't break fast it's ketosis
friendly and you know I'm always in that
state of ketosis
they also have caffeine free flavors the
pink is cute if you just want a tasty
beverage cheers to gamer stuff what
flavor did you get I am queen I'm doing
other people for no money well I'm gonna
need help
I'm on a podcast and I'm like better
help is so amazing and I'm like they
won't they dropped me right me too by
the way yeah I didn't want to work with
us yeah they dropped the [__] out yeah
now it's all about cerebral
they're like they're cool with
Hannah
I bless him enough said really
yeah apparently
um it's nice right tastes like black
cherry Kool-Aid that's what I'm saying
and this guy's caffeine it's gamer sup
myself my hands under the table for a
percent of the check right now
what do you what flavors you guys like
blue raspberry I don't know if I've
tried blue red there's a guy that I said
I'm sorry
there basically is
it's under the seat you ever hear those
rumors about the seats with CO2
cartridges that shoot up people's ass no
what do you what what there was always
this rumor that I heard as a kid
because apparently there's the way that
the seat goes up where where are these
at like Chipotle or oh no the seats
we're in right now
apparently this is probably not even
true but the seat goes up with the CO2
cartridge that's not true right Dan
that's totally made up oh like you're
saying co2s was I thought it was like a
death thing there and my when I was a
kid they say sometimes the CO2 cartridge
was shoot out into people I've never
heard that and I believed it I don't
kind of chair they were sitting in
that's kind of fun anyway guys
please please please go to this link
because we're in trouble go to
gamersupps.gg H3 links in description
you get a free sample pack for the next
24 hours what the freak free did you
it's free sample Tech all you have to do
is hit add to the cart hit checkout
enter your mailing address and enter
your
mailing address and email address
you don't have to add a credit card or
anything as a good deal your total will
be zero dollars and you're gonna get a
free sample sent right to your door
after you missed the 24 hour window you
can always still use code H3 for 10 off
your order
it's free
go there get it get a free sample You're
Gonna Love It gamer sup
[Music]
gamersupps.gg H3 thank you we love you
gamer Subs forgive me
look at the end of the day
uh Dan and ELO were like if we would
kill button that right now if we could
I can't change who I am I know that's
why that's why the kill button is on its
way that's it see exactly we had to get
a kill button twenty thousand dollar
Hardware where twenty thousand dollars
okay it's like what the NBA uses and and
like live broadcast okay so that there
we can be live and then if I say
something horrible which happens like
this episode brought to you
but that was funny but that was funny I
made a laugh that was it that was worth
it so what you press the kill button and
what it erases it it goes back
still run the risk that someone was
screening Courtney yes no so it runs
through this machine on a 30 second
delay okay so then if we hit the kill
switch
is gone nobody sees it so the live
stream will have a little bit of a delay
30 second delay oh that's six oh yeah
the coolest thing is like it what did
you say about how it gets the kill spot
back again Dan
oh it'll then afterwards Play Slightly
in fast motion so that it can get that
delay slow motion right right no exactly
yeah if they had that across my career I
would be sponsored by Coca-Cola right
for sure right now I would be in
McDonald's
arches right that's a [__] lutely
that's insane yeah and that's so funny
being so self-aware
foreign
oh my God but I don't get it it's like
are you guys really babies like you're
sponsoring me you know what it is I I
you know what I mean it's like stop it
it's so so so wild I I've you know what
I mean I'll take my fashion novas and my
my vibrator deals and myself that's
everything but then I get a weird Rogue
one always where it's like this one you
know what I mean you sure they're like
yeah like someone like audible comes
you're like yeah I'm like are you
[__] sure yeah and then like one
person sends them an email and then
they're like never again oh absolutely
well I do have Tourette's though for the
record gamer stuff if you if you
complain you're ableist
that's lit just saying that's lit God
gifted you there by the Lord
what is the anyways so thank you to them
moving on so
you moved to California when you were
18. or before that well I I think
technically like 18 but I was staying
with friends for like six months at a
time and like [__] like that until I
could actually sign a lease what were
your parents thinking when you were like
with your friend's family for six months
were they trying to get you back were
they trying to make contact
did they not care or you feel like you
don't you want to say yeah I mean maybe
all of the above they were probably like
[__] yeah we have five more dollars
today to not feed this rat I'm just
kidding I actually don't know
um
I mean well usually it would be
something awful would happen you know or
something in my opinion something would
happen where it'd be like okay I gotta
go I'm out you know what I mean and then
it
it would just be you know what I mean so
you would need I always thought yeah
like it was a lot like I I felt a lot
like it was like my fault you know what
I mean and it like obviously you grow up
now and you realize none of it was your
fault but at the time it was like well
you you know what I mean it it felt like
I was choosing to leave and I was you
know yeah as you've grown up and been
through therapy and stuff you notice
kind of how this really
messed up unorthodox relationship with
your parents like manifests in your own
experiences of dealing with people
absolutely all my I think for so long
even just in my relationships I
definitely Associated and not knowingly
do you know what I mean but you
associate turbulence and chaos and
toxicity with love you you learn little
Zan is now we make like all my toxic
relationships absolutely just you know
what I mean you think you think love has
to be earned you think that you know
what I mean you there's no pull without
push there's no good without bad and you
have to
severely hard re-hardwire your brain and
I still struggle with that like when I'm
when something's just so healthy my
innate reaction is like I'm bored but
it's like you're not bored you just
don't think this is love or you just
weren't conditioned to think this is
love and you have to really
hardwire your brain in a different way
100 so is that and that's common with a
lot of people you know what I mean just
you grow up in a toxic turbulent abusive
volatile household and you're learned
you're learning at such a young age like
this is what love is you know what I
mean
So when you say like I'm I'm kind of
over that error is that kind of what you
mean we're like you've kind of been able
to associate
what love means to you in a healthier
way yeah and I'm able to
you know maybe innately I'll always want
to go for that but at least now I'm able
to
I think just to sit there and be like
okay this isn't right I can't I can't do
this this isn't healthy this isn't you
know what I mean instead of just being
like
love this is you know what I mean yeah
it's a love a little toxicity for fun
that'll always be yeah it's here yeah I
feel that the bad boy that was the hand
I was down I guess my bad boy Ula do you
think I'm a bad boy didn't we do a poll
and people actually thought I was a bad
boy
we did do a poll I don't remember the
results I'd have to go check you're like
in a way because there are there could
be situations where like you're you're
not even aware of the rules you've so
like yeah maybe more like you don't play
where the world so much locally so
theoretically would you consider this
bad boy Behavior saying that I think
someone should hypothetically as a joke
not even a serious thing I did once say
and it got us into a lot of trouble
somebody should bleep the NRA
headquarters okay and that's not I
didn't mean that yeah
is that bad boy Behavior or is that just
psycho baby I think you're verbally a
bad boy I think you're very physically
not like I don't see you showing up to
someone's house word to Jeff
um I don't see you sending goons to
someone else I don't see you
stealing I don't see you I feel like
violent crime makes you a physical bad
boy all right yeah or I don't see you
doing drugs or I don't see you treating
her like [__] but I see you
I see you saying some [__] okay okay
you're a bad boy all right I agree with
that I mean when it comes to the core
things though he never does like bad you
have a mouth on you yeah when your
parents die will you come back for a
pillow that'd be fun absolutely I'm
gonna do a book tour I want you to be
here I can't wait for that scoop well
you need that I actually like that Oprah
interview this conversation even today
it's like we were
I was referencing earlier it's it's nice
to talk about different things and
things you don't need to talk about and
maybe help someone versus like what's
Jake Paul's [__] look like oh I just
spoke crack once
did you really yes was it cocaine in
something it was no something I had a
friend who's like a real degenerate okay
and he had cocaine and he like turned it
into crack with a penny yeah you use
like a penny okay you know about that
Through the Grapevine not through
personal experiences so I did that yeah
so what kind of crazy stuff did you get
what did you what did you feel like I
did it I was I didn't hit it very hard
yeah so I think we were drunk and high
at the time so yeah I didn't feel it
necessarily so I didn't really know I
didn't hit the pipe really hard because
I was nervous yeah I've been in some
situations where people are I guess
smoking cocaine so you could make this
was Vegas long time ago not something I
would do now did I just say I did a
Christmas tree what's wrong with that I
always talk about my crack experience
I've done a lot of drugs but you're
you're so reformed like you're like the
father now I'm gonna be leaving like
Ketch steak on like a nice date this
week and there's gonna be like a
Paparazzi like Tana did you do crap just
say yeah what's up I guess that's all
you really yeah shout out does fashion
Nova they'll give a [__]
fashion Nova actually can't do a crack
with the CEO actually interesting
I just read a sponge answering G Lane
Maxwell she does really nice fits well
they do have a whole Blazer two-piece
that's section you know what I mean yeah
she looks good for an older lady yeah
there's so many really
you can make right now that was like
such a setup for like maybe 12 jokes but
I think that it's in my messenger you're
smarter than me
um but just know I'm thinking to learn
but I love gamer stuff I just made a
little joke to make Tana laughs well I'm
in mine but I love gamer sub what was
about to understand I'm in my own sense
of humor era I credit Jeff Foley I I've
always said this I have I have like if
we were off camera I probably would have
made the joke sometimes I I forget that
there's a platform and
you know
not I don't know who I'm telling this
but it sometimes I just don't want to
say things on a platform but my sense of
humor is very dark for sure I believe
you the darkest it could possibly be but
you know
oh she's in jail yeah she's she's
chilling
is that is that just like done
um I mean she's in jail I don't I think
did she have her trial already what's
that can we get some G Lane Maxwell
updates yeah she was sentenced to
20 years
I think that's right oh I like G Lane
which I don't think that's right
G Lane has the same lawyer as Harvey
Weinstein let's [__] go she's got
sentenced he sure did I'd like for the
third time he's so [__] yeah what
still he's getting something awesome
because like he's been sentenced in like
a bunch of different states oh my God
he's getting thrown around like a hot
potato like a raping Hot Potato
absolutely which is awesome it's so
awesome like I I love to see it you know
that's so you had mentioned that people
have asked you what Jake Paul's dick
looks like what does it look like
foreign
wait wait he what Harvey Weinstein got
charged for raping the governor of
California's wife that's right really no
way well she wasn't I'm assuming this
was years ago she was an actress whoa
but she is now currently married to
Gavin you know he's [__] Gavin Newsom
yep wow his wife he's our governor oh my
God you know if I was him I would be
like boy
I don't know how you can [__] with them
anymore I mean the guy's in jail forever
yeah
crazy
so um cybel Newsom
is she famous I don't know who she is
good for her though Justice for Sybil
Sybil
Bible Justice for cyborg do you think
newsom's hot he's handsome isn't he
they're a really good looking couple
he's slick no way he looks like that
yeah he's super handsome he's like slick
as [__] dude no way maybe the most
beautiful Governor ever a character from
a comic movie to me you know what I mean
like yeah two-faced right before he got
like
acid what's his name American Psycho oh
totally oh yes Christian Bale yeah
Christian Bell
yeah he's a handsome king no way
and he's aging like fine wine
he takes really good care of himself you
can tell have you ever been in LAX in
the airport and they play the thing
that's like this is Gavin Newsom and
don't have an unintended bag and it's
like the most random thing ever oh my
God I remember being in LAX being like
he sounds hot yeah like yeah he's got a
lot of people think he might become pres
one day Dan what do you think about that
are you Pro Gavin Newsom uh I am not
super pro Gavin Newsom no but I but yeah
he's he's almost certainly yeah every
politician but yeah I mean I have no
political views you know what I mean
like if JFK was President like in this
day and age he could have been doing
anything and I would have been like yes
daddy slay and it's just you know I
think he was
yeah um well that's okay I mean honestly
I didn't get really interested in
politics so I was like in my 30s to be
totally honest with you that's true
because yeah I forget that we're like oh
[__] I'm 37. that's like not old I'm 30.
you're so you're like 24 you said yeah
that's amazing I'm like 80 kind of about
the drama right emotionally 80. no no
life experience I have a lot to go for
sure but it's are you happy when you see
and this is no shade because I love this
man I love him you know I do I came on
here with him when you see like Mike
maylak would you ever want a lifestyle
like that yeah how old is Mike he's all
this [__] too he's
your age I believe this election what I
uh what I want to trade lives with Mike
I mean uh my life is way cooler than
Mike's
my life rules
Mike just hangs out with porn stars all
day
and has sex with porn stars and is Rich
and doesn't have kids and you know the
kind of free time and goes to shows and
does fun things there's another porn
star and he just uh you know who would
want that life boring what a [__]
loser tomato tomato
he cruises around Saudi Arabia whips
what is this photo lock screen I sent it
to like nine people I knew I love this
Photograph who wouldn't want to he
probably toured Saudi Arabia and whipped
Filipino slaves that they have they're
building like buildings and [__] here we
go they were just like eating Burger
that's so awesome client gone from
private jets no my life's awesome I
definitely [__] Mike
have you had him back on since our beef
squashing no but I do love Mike he's
actually really nice we texted a little
bit Yeah I appreciate you having me on
so much after that episode like I just
we we know the story I got the surgery
and it was off painkillers and I was
just like not a human but I was so
scared that I would never get to go back
on and that would be like my H3 Peak no
I'm so happy we're friends because I I
genuinely am this is nice I feel like
this this is a bestie thing I love it I
love it we're giving
new three Frenemies yeah no better sorry
here's what kind of it's just so hard
not to pick enough situations you can't
talk about like um that's the one in our
life yeah that really sucks because like
Ethan is such an open person and I am
too like when it comes to our online
stuff I mean we pretty much share it I
don't think literally everything yeah
like does that bother you do you is it
legal that you can't say things that I
can't talk about this Frenemies oh that
well that that's just like a personal
not legal yeah just family and that
doesn't bother me I've talked about that
[__] so much now there's nothing left to
say about it do you guys you're like
there's nothing left to say about it I'm
like well I mean let's scroll
um no you can ask for whatever you want
and if I if uh I don't want to talk
about it then I won't like do you guys
still speak with Moses no
and it's really hard Moses to me Moses
is yours my brother your brother isn't
that crazy it's not really hard it's
really hard very close your whole life
yes dude we used to hang out with him he
was the closest one every week dude no
really no time and then and um it's
really hard on my whole family that we
don't talk because they they were there
I have two other siblings yeah they talk
with him yeah and my mom obviously it's
very hard to be the one so like we can't
have like a holiday together we can have
like you wouldn't be in the same room
yeah and so I would sooner
I'm just going to say it I would sooner
make up oh don't say it I'm out no I
don't want you to say that I know what
you expect
hey this is me right now verbal bad boy
also smoke crack once like someone just
[__] made that at a [__] desk
right here you're telling me that yeah
yeah I'm about to relaunch my podcast
and I swear to God I could be doing it
for 10 [__] years I I just I don't
know if it's the people I attract I
don't know what it is I just sorry to
all the people I just hired I don't
think you're cute
well cam can't I'm actually kidding
Cam's job is to sit there and make memes
during the show he's really good at it
that's it I mean that's incredible I
actually did just um hire some people
that do Jeff Jeff's Jeff FM and they are
like that good so that's good Jeff the
Jeff FM guys yeah yeah they're okay they
look good did you poach them
did I poached them yeah I mean not not
really no I mean it's it's like we're a
happy family okay that's always down to
just extend he always is like what's
mine I appreciate it you know I have the
same offer what's mine is yours but I
don't think he needs like a spray tan
girl at 3am like and smoke weed with him
so I don't really have much to offer him
in that regard but I appreciate it a lot
by the way this is the Justin Bieber guy
he's such a dollar store Justin Bieber
he's like Wish Justin Bieber and I know
that's a joke
but this is so accurate it's so it's so
wow he's like the Justin Bieber Action
doll I didn't realize before because
that a picture was far I'm like it's so
funny they always look good to me you
know I can't no he's handsome don't get
me wrong it's just funny how he looks
like Justin Bieber
he kind of looks like Leonardo in that
one
I mean obviously but like
I'm just kidding okay Dollar Store
Justin Bieber
that's crazy what is he up to now is he
not doing the music actually he is
making music normally I get the musician
and then I like ruin their life so hard
they're like either quitting their job
in Life or they're making awful music
about me but this was a reverse effect
where he broke up and he became a
musician and he wrote a lot of songs
about our
yeah his last post got 900 likes how
does that make you feel 14 weeks ago I
form now I feel
different I'll stop you feel something I
really don't okay okay because it's like
I would hate if someone said that about
me if I was like getting no likes he
said sold out show
last Friday took me a few days to take
but like how if there's not the if you
sold out there's definitely less than
this many people and obvious
as well oh this was
obviously as well let's see it was you
know three four years ago when I was
really bitter like [__] you I gave you
everything and you cheated on me like
you're a rat like I made you when I was
angry like that I that would have but
now I just you've moved on nothing yeah
that's good that means you moved on
Bella Thorne wrote a song about you
called stupid [__] [__] oh my God
give that girl a Grammy oh my God girl
Grammy she did not mince words at all
hired a girl in the music video who
looked like me it was I filmed a
reaction to it which I think equated
maybe in views to her song I don't even
know which made me feel I don't know
about all of this
um
yeah it's a it's a banger
oh my God was that a really a hateful uh
thing she did or was she being cheeky
like what was it it was kind of cheeky
like some of the words were like you're
you're stupid but I I don't remember you
know what I mean like you're a stupid
[__] [__] like I hate that I loved
you it was like kind of
why does she hate you so much
um it's it's a long story but it's
basically like I started dating her
um and it was right as I was kind of
moving out here like fine and I credit
so much of my like Fame and success to
her she was my first like break into the
mainstream world and she taught me so
much whatever
um but we were dating and then
a couple months into US kind of dating
or whatever it was she brought in this
guy mod Sun this singer she started just
dating him he was around all the time
and it was very it was very much an
environment of it felt like we were like
competing for her you were in an open
thing with her yeah but then it got
weird yeah and then the narrative in the
press all of a sudden was throuple
thrupple throupled they're in a trouble
they're all dating whatever the in
pretty much the entire time so this was
like a year of this where it was just
like I was dating Bella and so was he
and it wasn't true and then like we were
just dating her and then eventually we
became friends through that but you guys
were never together
well at that time no oh so that they
were getting okay so then um we were
both just dating her and for a while we
we really didn't get along it was like
who's getting her the better [__]
Valentine's Day gift and oh my God we
have to do a matching costume and [__]
this and whatever but it was what she
wanted and we both wanted to almost like
a Mormon it reminds me of like the
Mormon reality shows I've seen where
they like to live out in America just a
[__] up weird La Stoner version
showers uh I shower now I'm performing
but really what's the longest you've
gone without a shower
like genuinely curious I don't I mean I
don't I don't actually know the uh
specifically we're talking like five
plus days have you have you ever been
probably yeah have you ever been so
depressed or you just I don't even you
know what I mean you're rotting in a bed
and you know I've been very depressed
but I don't think I've gone more than
three days without a shot that's really
that's my man that's really good I've
been the thing is a suicidal depressed
where I just didn't leave a bed for like
probably like six days you know what I
mean yeah yeah but I feel I'm
particularly greasy
the internet disagrees but um uh so
basically towards the very end
Bella like mod sun and I were vibing a
lot more because like I was I felt like
me and Bella were on the out Tim and
Bella were definitely on the outs so it
was kind of like oh my gosh she's so
[__] you know what I mean we were
bonding over that and then him and her
broke up before
or no her and I broke up before him and
her broke up
um or I was dating the Brad because I
was also open with it too I was dating
Justin Bieber guy eventually got so
serious and Belle and I were just
fighting all the time and we were trying
to mix business and work it wasn't
working we broke up and then a couple
months later whatever her and mod Sun
break up and then we just mod sun and I
just Bond we click we're like [__] this
past two years of our life we started
hanging out a lot I was in my music
making era so he was also helping me
with all of this music [__] so I was
spending a lot of time with him
eventually him and I start dating and
she is which is such a you'd think we
would have just done it then you know
what I mean like in our throttle
situation but we didn't and then she was
very much so angry Girl Code how could
you that's funny because
yeah I'm like Girl Code [__] you just
made me [__] look like I was dating
him from the last [__] two years and
you were fine with it when it was
interesting in your world with your
control but now you hate it because we
broke up with you and we don't like you
and that's what it felt like and we just
went back and forth and back and forth
and it was all online and it was so
messy and yeah but then I mean
eventually we both grew a lot and just
kind of let bygones be bygones we both
said and did a lot of mean [__] and
you know we were young and it was stupid
was it was there any weird or awkward I
can imagine when you have two people
dating the same girl
and were you guys over like in the same
house together a lot and would it would
she ever let go with him and hook up and
you're like sitting on the couch like
[__] like that or did I just imagine
like all these awkward situations
like yes and no it was never awkward
though like we were all very close so
we'd just be like chilling like there
were always other people around that
we'd all just be like hang out with or
I'd just be with them it's not like they
were like whatever just like leave to go
[__] I guess or if they did it'd be like
we're all with our friends and then
they'd come back like 20 minutes later
like you know what I mean and I'd be
like oh cool like it didn't
I I did I was in mind just very open
wild La dating crazy era so it wasn't
like there was so much
like I wasn't frustrated with that I
guess like at all it didn't really like
bother me
so growing up is kind of like a
parentless
hooligan in Vegas what kind of trouble
did you get yourself into
everything I was banned from like half
of the Strip by the time I was 18. we're
just being like drunk being underage
being drunk I sold drugs like
for money for like a big
not a big portion just like a portion of
life I was just
reckless in every way what kind of drugs
were you selling all of them anything
yeah so you would go to like your your
dealer and just whatever they had you
would buy like or like I just like had a
lot of friends who were caught up in the
same world so it became
it became so normal you know what I mean
like you just that was like a way
and at that you know what I mean like I
I wasn't getting financial help in any
way I dropped out like it you feel like
this is the only way I'm gonna
make ends meet right now I guess and
it's
I don't I was never like a mass drug
dealer I was never like you know what I
mean like it was just like a here and
there thing for where would you would
you sell to like people who came by
where you were like people I knew yeah
people just friends that I knew yeah but
that also I guess would extend you know
friend of a friend
um yeah I just you had to make ends meet
so you're banned from but you're selling
drugs oh my God yeah being awful like
just being like 16 hooking up with like
[__] awful just nasties or just way
older like just you know what I mean
just yeah awful decisions in every
regard and moving to La was so amazing
like I I say this all the time you know
what I mean this lifestyle like saved my
life this job this career path this
journey absolutely saved me in my life
from like [__] everything so I thank
God I was able to get out of it before
it was not you know what because it is I
could write it off it's like I was just
young and dumb and it was an ERA I'm
like you know like thank God but people
get caught up in that and that becomes
people's actual lives yeah yeah
definitely I'm very lucky were you
always like a funny kind of like
charismatic person where you're like I
maybe can turn this into a career like
yeah what made you think that honestly
yeah I think it takes takes one a small
bout of narcissism in any regard to put
on a camera and think I
I'm gonna film myself and put this on
the internet and people might enjoy it I
guess right
um but I've always just been crazy loud
wild saying whatever is on my mind and I
accredit that almost to no one ever
telling me like that's wrong I guess
right
um
so yeah and I I just love I don't know I
loved YouTube I loved like Shane Dawson
and I love like Jenna Marbles and all
that [__] and I wanted to do it what's
your opinion on Shane since like have
you talked about or talked to him about
since like his major cancellation
yes the last time I spoke to Shane was
at a Jeffree Star skin event probably
like
eight months ago nine months ago we've
spoken over messaging a couple times
since then and
it's it's interesting
um because Shane was my idol Shane was
my world like he's the only he saved my
life and he's the only reason I ever
started your life how did you save your
life in the regard of like in so many
ways really but it it began with like I
fell in love with the idea of him and
his sense of humor as well him joking
about [__] up [__] obviously that
didn't age well but I'm saying at the
time
um
to make light of trauma and to provide
an escape for people who might need it
and I was that person who needed it you
know what I mean like I loved you know
my household's full-blown chaos awful
I'm crying I hate my life and for five
minutes of a day I get to escape in
Shane Dawson's day gets to make me laugh
and that saved me in so many requests
was the escapism of it all and then
I don't think I I think he genuinely
like the things that he was saying
empowered me enough to think maybe I can
do this too which also saved my life in
regard and then I
accredited so much of you know what I
mean like I blew up because I made this
video because he inspired me and then I
met him and then at the time he he was
so there for me day in and day out and
like mentored the [__] out of me I'm
like how to do this and how to
deal with all of the emotions of this
lifestyle and
also just you know like pointers
business pointers you're really funny
doing this keep doing this blah blah
blah was there for me for years and
years all tanacon all that just
everything though like you know what I
mean
um so it was hard for me when he got
canceled like I I was sad
people always say you like live long
enough to see your Heroes become like
villains in a regard and that's what it
felt like for sure and then it has you
kind of second guessing
everything you know what I mean like I I
for so long I was just like oh my God
now I can recognize he shouldn't have
made that joke and
was that did that did our senses of
humor at that time make our relationship
inappropriate or so on and so forth and
I think throughout it all it just made
me question everything and kind of gave
me a
it was almost like a new chapter in my
world I guess and
um
after speaking to him
and see I'm saying this in the same
regard as other conversations we've had
where I can't even think of all the
jokes he made and I'm sure I could sit
here and be like I think he's changed I
think he's grown and someone could pull
up one joke that's [__] awful and
unforgivable and say you're so wrong for
forgiving him for that so it's it's a
hard water to tread in but like
he from what I see because I don't see
him all the time I don't talk to him all
the time but when I have spoken to him
and what I see
I feel like he's on a really great path
now which is good
and it's just it's he wasn't weird he
hasn't been doing he wasn't doing
controversial content for a while yeah
and then everyone's like oh [__] he was
doing like black face and like yeah like
that [__] he's asking his young cousin
about sex yeah that [__] is absolutely
inexcusable yeah
um it is a question though it's like and
it's just so weird the way the internet
works like certain people have been
canceled for
worse things are still filming a video
and posting it to this day you know what
I mean like the line on the internet
of who gets forgiven and who doesn't and
yeah it's very interesting to me there
was this one tweet you liked that I was
interested in
you said if this person tweeted the fact
Shane Dawson made Tana Mojo pee on him
as soon as she turned 18 doesn't sit
right with me I can't believe I watched
that video and thought it was funny
that's like your number one most viewed
video that's it's one of them for sure
that was that's kind of what I was
saying in reference to there was an
error where I was questioning everything
do you know what I mean you're looking
back and yeah and that like at that time
like I probably liked so many tweets
like like that about that time about
everyone Vlog Squad [__] everything and
I think now I've come to conclusions
about how I feel like about that
situation I can honestly look back and
say that
it's not like I literally peed on him
like it was that's what I was gonna ask
so in a regard like yeah you never you
didn't pee on him no I didn't like
physically actually no Pete touched him
we made it seem like I did do you know
what I mean but I knew what I was doing
it's one of my most viewed videos he
wasn't getting off there was no like
sexual yeah like I can come to a
conclusion now that I think it was too
far and we were constantly making too
far [__] up jokes but at the time the
internet loved that [__] so we
normalized the [__] out of it because it
didn't matter but I don't look at that
as trauma like I don't look at that now
as like that was really [__] weird
and I I need to like you know what I
mean I just look at it as like a
different time too far wild for sure
but
what's your guys's age difference like
how old is Shane uh pretty big one I
think so that I see that it was so he's
34 so he's like my age like 10 years old
10 years I mean but he's so you're 18
he's 28. that's kind of a big difference
I could see him being like making sexual
videos with you and I think that he had
a lot of growing up to do too in the
regard that like he was just always
filming videos with all of the anyone
who had clout at the time you know he
was in his View getting [__] era you
know yeah he was filming all these
videos with that same raunchy sense of
humor with all of these upcoming
people some young and I think that he
was still in that very young like
mindset and he had a lot of growing up
today there's one bit he does that
always blows my mind which is that
puppet
the puppet the little girl puppet who's
like trying to have sex with everyone
she's like eight
it's so [__] up it like it's just it
makes me it's so gnarly here let me show
you one
he oh you know it was so crazy he did it
with the Fine Bros the [__] Fine Bros
and they never got heat for it that and
that's kind of what I mean is that
everyone just had a dark ass sense of
humor and that was okay and it was a
joke at that time because I remember
laughing at every single Shane Dawson
video ever yeah yeah but you're oh
really yeah you remember Millie
this [__] was some of these jokes or
you're like what the [__] and I remember
thinking this was the funniest thing
ever yeah he looks so different oh my
God you're talking about your big dick
why was he like hot he was hot no he
definitely was in that cute little cute
boys that cute boy era like the Smosh
cute boy hair era
I don't ever remember being like Shane
Dawson's hot
but like I
so Millie you a fan of the date are you
talking about
that's just like right off the bat it's
like what because she's like eight
it's [__] crazy
stick me what no I was talking about D
like DZ man where did you learn how to
talk like that from watching Selena
Gomez Selena Gomez yeah
attractive
I love the way your hair flows down her
back and brushes over her child it's one
thing with the puppet but then like
that's that's Rogue that's Rogue
that's not yeah I mean but this is
that's not even the worst thing this
puppet done I remember them yeah
let me just click this but at the time
it just so wasn't which is crazy yeah
because you were a kid that's fair and
the adults had no idea what was going on
in YouTube yet right can you imagine
you're like what the [__] you see your
young daughter hey you want to suck my
dick
like that's crazy oh did you see all
that water but and that that like what
also puts air so much to like like 10
million people probably watched that if
you know what I mean yeah so like
Society also I thought it was funny and
kept coming back I think that's why
people it is kind of like a grooming
thing it's weird because you're
normalizing like an eight-year-old girl
being sexual which is not normal and
maybe that was a lot of what YouTube was
as well it was like [__] that you just
couldn't look away from do you know what
I mean because people were
figuring it out like you know what I
mean and they were like their kids views
people can't look away kept but now you
can like acknowledge that yeah yeah not
the correct right route there's been a
lot of awareness and all that kind of
stuff it wasn't just Shane I think there
was a lot of [__] up [__] it was me I
said so much [__] crazy yeah I mean I
guess I have my age to help me with that
but um still I want to see one more
I love you for subscribing bye
[Music]
why is it just showing your [__]
hey hey
what is it wrong to touch yourself in
the nether regions bro and it's shot
like a snuff film like this is not okay
can I ask you a question Shane what she
will you [__] me
bro
that is not funny at all like that would
be like that's that is just vile vile
[__] that's for kids they're just kids
watching this [__] I see people in chat
saying I was shaped my brain
I think I think Shane traumatizes you
more than your parents
definitely not I see people in chat
saying they were 12 years old when they
watch this
it's so wrong but it's like that and
that's what we'll never know about all
of these things is like at this time was
his thought process the same as the
viewer like you know what I mean like
this is just Rogue and funny and people
are watching and whatever you know and
that and that's where I think a lot of
the cancellation came from where it was
like is it that or is it something
darker and deeper
I think he I think in my opinion he
thought he was just I don't think he
knew what he was doing was so [__] up
if I had to guess I could be wrong I
know a lot of people think the the
problem the reason the cancellation was
so serious is just the amount of stuff
yeah absolutely it's so much and it was
it all kind of happened at once as well
in the regard that it was just like
we've pulled up these hundred thousand
things that he said all at once which
obviously also was so bad always and
then the smith thing really [__] him
up when this whole Smith family came
down on him oh was that the like actual
girl who used to be in his Vlogs is that
what you're talking about no there was a
picture of him in a Subway here pull
that up like he would he said something
about
um Willow Willow Smith Oh wanting to
[__] her when she was like 12. oh like
the Smiths yeah yeah yeah I was thinking
everything else that yeah and like what
was it like potato was like keep my
kid's name out of your mouth they love
that
[Laughter]
what do you think of that the Will Smith
moment hated it Oh I thought it was
disgusting I I hated it I think he's a
piece of [__] for that you loved it
didn't you yeah you're [__] up like
that you're like I want my man
no I wasn't gonna say it I love it but I
I love to watch it at least oh I love to
watch the man did that I probably like
that would be everything for you well in
the moment I would have like yes slay
and then later I would have been like oh
maybe not but the thing is he definitely
didn't do it for his wife did it because
like he's so [__] insecure she's not
emasculated him so much that's true but
uh here here's a disgusting video found
by
this user where Shane pretends to
masturbate over a poster of 11 year old
Willow Smith oh that's way worse than I
thought oh there's a video of it yeah
this was yeah I think there is a reason
yeah yeah what I'm fighting it and he
like says her name what would make you
think
this is funny this is crazy yeah what
would make you think this is funny that
was like the one of the big ones of it
huh here we have the video
Paris Hilton
oh
[Laughter]
yes so yeah there's some he's really
something really [__] up here
you know it's like whoa tough watch not
having me yeah well then they got
receipts on Jeffree Star are you cool
with him
I'm just trying to get some Yak meat
we got some [__] yakme you want to
try it what we got your someone just
running from the back to get the yak
right we've got Jeffree Star Yak me you
did yeah really you know we got we've
got all the strings how does it what is
it I don't think I'm gonna oh it's a
jerky yeah it's jerky I'm like I'm I
can't lie like I would I want to go to
stariak Ranch
what's happening there what's stopping
you what's happening there I don't know
it ain't Yaks it comes in this bag
yeah this that's those I think I'll have
this on Deck is so right it looks like
weed or something I mean am I trying
this right now it's really dry but I
don't know hold on I mean he took that
money if you get sick
it tastes like beef jerky
wait why is it so hard my veneers cannot
bite into this I will yeah you think
it's too hard I would break a tooth 100
yeah
really crazy why is it so hard it smells
good it kind of smells like pepperoni
this was in jerky form oh
give it a shot no well you're not gonna
taste it
I literally the veneer of it all I can't
What food did you avoid to protect your
videos it's too hard to chew um like if
a bread on a sandwich is too hard oh
okay or like especially if it's front
teeth it's one thing if you can get it
in the back on like a real tooth you
know what I mean like have you ever
ripped one out yeah oh no oh yeah
several times and then I had like oh my
God can you tell me about veneers so it
goes over your tooth they shave your
teeth down really depending on how much
they overlap kind of is what
um
decides how much they shave down and
then they just put like a tooth over
it's I honestly like
I don't recommend them I'm on my third
set holy [__] I'm about to be on my
fourth set I think because they shift
like as you can see here it moves
they're supposed to last a while at
least they pitch it like they do but I
also am out here getting them for like a
pop tag in like a [__] you know what
I mean like an Instagram story you're
not going to the you're not you think
your doctors kind of suck the one you've
been going to I mean no Dr Gabe I love
you please give me my fourth step good
veneers cost like fifty thousand yeah
these These are priced that that good
videos cost more than that honestly good
ones
um what is it made of like [__] like
uh endangered Rhino Tusk no then
porcelain also like toilet paper
um my best friend actually frequently
calls me toilet seat teeth and it really
hurts my feelings that is for me I just
mean and why did you get it is it just I
I tried all the other rock my teeth are
just like not straight and like okay
um I just didn't like them okay and um I
tried Invisalign but I'm just bad with
things like that like there were hot
Cheetos in the trays at all times like
it was just like it's not it wasn't cute
at all it really wasn't cute and I'm
very much an instant fixer as well you
know like yeah yeah I get the appeal I
mean having beautiful teeth is like
great everybody it's just come on I
think
it's a quick way to do it you know but
the comp and but I'm also like I feel
like I'm in the 10 like 90 of people I
talk to have no complications with their
veneers they love them I think I also
had a lot of dental complications
growing up that were on was like
resolved and [__] so I just wasn't the
like dream case as is so I mean yeah I
don't know I have your teeth look right
yeah [__] it stay tuned for set number
four
so going back to
you growing up in Vegas when did you
drop out of school
when I was 15. high school middle of
sophomore year
would something happen or what like how
do you actually leave High School I
thought there was like that was illegal
or something well
it is but I just feel like Vegas doesn't
give a [__] if you look at the if you
rank the school system the school
systems are ranked from like best to
worst all 50. Vegas is 50th or it was
for a long time I don't know if it still
is I remember seeing that 49th or Nevada
is but I mean it's they don't give a
[__] but I mean
I think it was leading up to it like I I
just for years of my life I was I've
always had really bad insomnia there was
a lot of fighting in my household I
would never sleep at night like I was
like scared to fall asleep I had really
bad insomnia so I'd be sleeping through
class all day like every day and [__]
like because I wasn't getting any sleep
I remember so many times our teachers
were like would send me for like a
wellness check at my school because why
is she like in REM sleep like it's one
thing they touch and you get up like I
wouldn't get up like type of thing well
I just
I hated the rules I hated Authority I
didn't want to learn I hated life so I
was like why the [__] what am I doing
this for a future I'm gonna [__] kill
myself what like there's no purpose
um
and yeah I mean and then it would just I
remember one of the last times my
parents took me to school
oh my God here I go again though am I
gonna get [__] sued
I feel [__] up it's like this happened
to you I know it's insane just maybe if
you say
I had a dream this is the way that I
remembered it yeah it could have
happened differently yeah yeah
um I just I remember
I was in the car and [__] got so bad
that I remember in my opinion yeah I
remember in my opinion I was so angry
that I got out and I was walking to
school and it was freezing outside and
now we're far a [__] from my school and
it was like 30 [__] degrees out and
I'm walking to school in like flip-flops
and like a t-shirt and I'm freezing and
then
I'm they're screaming from the car to
not the car whatever people call the
police like police show up whole thing
and I'm just like walking is going I
remember being like I I don't want to go
back like it just like this is too much
I don't want to go back
um and so
I just stopped going I never like filed
the paper I never anything you just one
day stop going yeah nobody reached out
to you nobody asked any questions no I
literally just one day stopped I mean
and I had hundreds of absences as is I
think that it said it's great if you
died nobody was like is she alive
no I mean I was funny about it though I
was funny about it I'd be like picking
my friends up from school I went to I
went to all the like like senior
assemblies and [__] I would sneak into
the school and just like do the fun [__]
with my friends and be like I'm a senior
not at all
um and I I started just working as much
as I possibly could so I could at least
have money to put myself in a better
situation because that's right that's
how it was for me from an early age it
was like you have to get yourself out of
this survival yeah yeah
don't they ever send like social
services around to your house or
anything like that no never nobody ever
checked on you
um at one point there it's truancy when
you don't show up and they I think they
like I think they like sent a truancy
officer like one [__] time and then
they just like rang the doorbell no one
answer and they left like again that's
actually like a kind of like a Vegas
thing like I don't I mean I I don't know
I think but I'm I'm assuming that's not
happening in like the Hamptons I'm
assuming that's not happening and like
yeah you know they're probably
underfunded there's a lot of kids who
are probably 100 not the best upbringing
absolutely they just don't have the
resources and that's the thing too like
I feel like uh high school and all that
type of stuff and a lot of other towns
are very community based in the regard
to like all the parents are friends and
check on each other and all live in
similar neighborhoods and do you know
what I mean like Vegas just isn't
[__] it's not like that at all I
guess oh you probably don't know about
this but if you're trying to avoid
getting sued you just say in mind craft
so you say my parents picked me up in
Minecraft
no no way in that case in Minecraft no
way it's a it's a gag it's like an
online gag Minecraft oh my God it's
funny yeah it's funny yeah or you could
say in Roblox if that's your cup of tea
I mean what's crazy too is like I'm
really not that terrified of being sued
like you know and I that's one of many
many lawsuits I've gone through but how
many losses you might we might be kinder
in that regard I think Ethan is thinking
did we just become best friends right
because I'm on like my fifth right now I
remember those days now I'm just
um still haven't learned that's awesome
yeah I've won the majority of my
lawsuits I did lose one this past year
but um
normally I'm like [__] it I'll say it
sue me because it's
when someone when a business is suing
you or like uh you know what I mean or
it doesn't matter it's not like your
whole life's just funny yeah airing it
out so it's like yeah that's the only
one where I really like
yeah I tread lightly I guess so you were
so you dropped out of school you
immediately just went because can you
even work underage like was it hard to
find a job at 16 15. 14 you can do [__]
that's like
you know what I mean like you could go
with someone like Lawns or you could go
work for a company that's not like tax
right like happy they pay you cash yeah
exactly and then 15 is I think when it's
legal or at least it was then and I just
immediately so you went and people hired
you absolutely like I Was preparing for
it like at 14. like I was like I on my
15th birthday I think literally maybe a
day after my 15th birthday I was like
was that transition from being a student
to like a full-time worker at 15 uh what
was that what what did it feel was it
relief was it good I love it yeah I
actually I loved it because
I guess for me and it's sad but School
felt like something I was doing for no
reason yeah because it was like even if
I graduated with a no I'm not being sent
to college I'm not I'm not a straight A
student who's getting sent anywhere and
maybe I could have been if I applied
myself but I I didn't feel that way like
I had no motivation I was so depressed
and that was a very instant
gratification I'm getting paid I'm
making money I'm changing my life and
you know what I mean I liked my
co-workers I liked working I liked
applying myself to [__] I also always
worked in retail and I love clothes and
I love I love people I'm a people person
as well so I enjoyed like making my tips
and doing [__] like that off of
human interaction I loved it yeah and so
when you turn to 18 you moved to
California right
such a it's like people always call me
out for fact checking because I'm like I
did this when I was this age and it's
like not even at all
um well the age is less important you
moved out to California like what was
your plan when you arrived did you have
a place to stay or are you staying with
friends
um so do you remember O2L no I'm like
Ricky Dillon and like do you remember
those all those like JC Kalin and Kian
and whatever O2L Trevi Moran
um
was my first like La best friend and
like had been doing it far longer than
me and making money and I would always
stay with her our second life yeah these
guys yeah so Trevi has transitioned now
um whoa
um what's up but this is before this is
eight years ago yeah so you were homies
with these guys yeah interesting and
well no all of them kind of but Trevi
specifically which one's Trevi bottom
left
um
yeah this person and
um wait I would always stay with Trevi
and Trevi like really took me in and
kind of showed me the La ropes and then
eventually
for the I mean there were other
um like phase Banks was really like my
good friend and I would like be there a
lot and stuff that was like FaZe Banks
was like my second La black blanks
um we call them phase blanks but it's
it's affectionately affectionately I
love him he's my longest uh
um Banks and Trevi are my longest La
friends so they kind of brought me into
this world and I would stay there and
they all that type of stuff
um was it hard to transition or was it
kind of like you were making money by
the time you know anything I took away
longer to than I should I stayed in
Vegas a lot longer because I was like
scared I I'm like is this a lifelong
thing what if I moved to LA and I it
doesn't work and whatever
um so I was back and forth a lot at one
point I was renting a house in Vegas and
uh
um townhome in LA with my best friend
and um
yeah so no I made it I made it pretty
gradual which I think was good for me so
I didn't let La change me too hard off
rip you know
um where are you from California are you
guys from California
I'm from Ventura yeah so I've been in
California my whole life I'm from Israel
I grew up in Israel my whole life how
did you guys meet
we met when he came to Israel to visit
on a birth Birthright trip everybody
loves this story and it's like a trip
for Jewish people yes you know what
birth rate is yes so when you when you
go on a group
so when you go in a group there's a few
soldiers too yes so I was a soldier
and she liked my bad boy Vibe
you're so [__] cool I'm so cool I
pulled her I I this me going on H3 is
just a scheme to become her best friend
she's so [__] cool don't stop it like
you were a what you were a what like
tell me more about this culture
lifestyle very quickly please
I
May did I I don't remember what was your
soldier Duty I remember
so in Israel when you're when you're 18
after you finish school you have to do
the Army yeah and everyone does yeah
it's mandatory and
um for women it's two years and for men
it's three years generally yeah
um and then there's all kinds of jobs
that you might end up get so mostly the
guys go to like
um combat stuff so it's more like
physical and actual doing things
now they they did start giving women the
option to do that so that's kind of like
a later thing would you do that if you
had the option I never wanted to yeah I
didn't even want to do the Army
um but in Israel it's kind of like a big
deal if you don't do it yeah and I was
debating not doing it and it's like a
whole thing if you want to try to avoid
it you have to like really lie through
your teeth yeah like [__] your pants and
stuff and they would come to your home
and check on you and my parents would
not allow me to do that yeah by the way
then if you know someone that [__] their
pants when an army person came over to
check on them to look crazy
but so anyway a lot of people around me
also like my friends parents pulled me
aside and they're like listen you have
to do it you'll never get a job oh
really in interviews everybody will ask
you you can't do that so I um I did go
and then they asked me like what kind of
job would I want like because there's
different options and I was like I just
want something like that where I can go
back home every day so like just leave
me close like in Tel Aviv
um that was like the only thing I asked
when and I actually got that and it was
like the worst thing ever it was like I
just felt like I was wasting my life I
was just sitting in an office
um doing stupid like really stupid
menial computer work yeah and and
spending like an hour on the bus going
there an hour on the bus coming back
home going back home to my parents house
and basically you also make no money
like I made like a hundred dollars the
whole month oh my God so I we had we'd
have to also work on the weekend to try
to make money for myself to like oh
that's buy whatever sad yeah yeah so so
I hated that and then I asked for like a
change which is some you can put in a
request it's like a whole process I did
that and you don't know what you're
gonna get so it's a little bit of a
Gamble and then I got to go to this
place where it's like they actually send
you away from home and you go you spend
the whole week there and sometimes the
weekend too and then you go back home
like for a weekend and then go again to
the oh my God so it's like a it's it's a
lot more like army-like that explains so
much about you why you have so much like
value for the life that you live now you
know like I do that's awesome how much
you appreciate it but it's cool to know
that's work
so I I didn't think I wanted that but
when I got there it was actually a
really good experience for me because it
was like being away from home and I
didn't like being home to at the time my
dad was like really
difficult and so it was kind of like an
opportunity for me to go away from home
and try something new and bond with
people
um and you guys met him and then when I
was at that base doing that they were
like this there's this thing if you want
to apply for it where you basically go
on a week off and you just travel yeah
it's just like it's kind of like a bonus
you know yeah I do a lot of soldiers I
would imagine a lot of them sign up for
it I didn't even know about it so I
don't know how many people know about it
or how many people they find out about
it somebody so I so where I was in the
base there's like
yeah I think the it's of the Apocalypse
outside
yeah yeah it's not like a weird AC unit
so there's like a a person
um like a captain or whatever it is that
manages that whole department where I
was and I was his secretary so that was
my job there
um so it's sort of like a good role in a
way and I I don't know if that's why I
got that opportunity I don't really know
probably but you were there on
Birthright so I got to go on this trip
and he was one of the Americans we met
at the Holocaust Museum no you [__] I
think that's the first time we spoke to
each other this is my kind of Love Story
let me tell you something okay
um no [__] way and so was it
immediate like did you guys [__] that
night no we did not and we were both
smoking and I think we both took like
smoke breaks together a lot so we kind
of like looking so much that yeah a lot
of cigarettes period of time it was a
week okay and then you went home and you
guys and then and then I downloaded
Facebook I didn't know what that was
and Skype and we started talking you
weren't doing any of this yet you were
no Adore Me Yeah doing what like this oh
no oh yeah way before way way way way
before yeah I was in the entire Journey
on the internet has been yeah we made
our YouTube channel together when I was
living in Israel [__] it I'm gonna kill
myself because I'm gonna die the [__]
alone that's so [__] annoying oh my
one relationship across your whole
[__] career oh my God it is pretty
crazy
it is insane I moved to Israel
eventually because that was the only way
we could be together yeah I came here
first and I had like only six months to
be here and then I got kicked out
basically and he yeah he came to Israel
with me how long were you did you live
in Israel for five years five years with
her yeah and then like here it must have
been year two or three we made the
YouTube yeah I was going to art school I
tried to get into fashion they didn't
take me in yeah then the next year I
tried again
I love it everywhere for you right now
that's [__] awesome so and in that
art school I had to take a mandatory
video class and I was too shy to be in
the video so I would record him yeah and
show it in class which was so stupid
I would love to see that he just has a
puppet no they're super super weird
videos and then we ended up putting
those videos up on YouTube and that
became like our beginning and people
like one of them got gained some
traction well I was doing like slow I
was doing really stupid like dumb not
funny poorly shot sketches
those really didn't get any traction I
started doing these video edits that was
the first time people started to follow
me I would make these like um I don't
know let's see like uh that's a 10.
this video was like uh actually viral I
edited this
and this was like my first big break
warm it up
that cream pure vanilla
sweeteners so how did you transition
from so did you continue to gain
traction by doing edit based videos and
then you transitioned into slowly kind
of putting yourself in them and then
became a personality were you always
um reporting or discussing internet
kind of yeah camaraderie so this gave me
a little traction what really kind of
blew me up so to speak as I was started
making reaction videos specifically to
like pranks YouTube pranksters because
like nobody was calling them out at the
time so you were kind of in the very
beginning like you spearheaded the
reaction yeah industry reaction maybe
I don't know I revolutionized the genre
because they were the first commentary
channel to really do like sketches and
actually like write out like uh good
jokes and stuff yeah I can't say that
about myself thank you that's awesome I
don't want to sound I love knowing
people's origin especially people who
can continue to reinvent and stay on the
space for so long thank you so
interesting you too Queen and you too
you guys go though and now you're on I
love your life story that's fine thank
you yeah it's pretty it's been pretty
crazy
but I didn't know any of that the last
10 years has just been like pretty
domestic life yeah you know what I mean
but it's crazy how much we've been
through yeah it is sometimes I mean I
met him when I was 19. yeah like are you
guys ever just like in your La home like
should we go to the studio or Postmates
air one and you're like what the [__]
yeah yeah we're like what is our life we
used to be broke as a [__] we
lived in an apartment that was infested
I don't with rats and cockroaches it was
a studio apartment there was more
[__] we went through selling drugs
like you described yeah
to make enough money to pay rent
absolutely I smoked crap once I don't
know
different time though that's [__]
insane I mean the bond of struggling
with someone yeah and then I experienced
that with my friends I have not been so
lucky with that in love lasting but um
that it's a bond like no other mm-hmm
yeah it's been a lot actually one of the
videos we made
a reaction video I don't know if you can
find it you can hear a rocket going yeah
oh cause you're in Israel because
there's [__] they're shooting Rockets
into Israel that's insane yeah it was
pretty wild
yeah Ethan was there during like one
time when Rockets were getting to Tel
Aviv which is like rockets are made up
in my head Rockets are on Jim's
Restaurant and that's it that's crazy
yeah yeah it's a whole it's a different
world there it's just a different world
it's really tough there and people
really feel it I feel like now that I
get to go away and then when I come back
everything becomes more and more
noticeable to me like everybody's so on
edge all the time it's hard there
it's a hard life there for sure
I can't imagine you know what I mean it
probably makes you so calm here about
like when people are on edge about like
stupid [__] here you're like yeah shut
up but you know every place I'm learning
every place has its own stuff and here
you have this like mass shooting thing
that's so scary and police brutality
which is like something I've never
thought in Israel that's not I don't
know I mean I don't want to speak we
take our kids to school and there's like
armed guards and [__] you're like really
when I was a kid that wasn't a thing I
shouldn't ask where they go to school
yeah yeah you can ask but yeah just no
why would we but it's just it's just a
school I mean Kanye he's three so it's
not like yeah
um
but uh so now you're doing only fans is
that your main thing
um
I mean I it's it's up there with my main
sources of income it probably is number
one no matter what else is going on
um what I mean podcast brand stuff
podcasts Investments dizzy
um I'm sorry I'm launching a weed brand
oh yeah dizzy how is dizzy doing dizzy
is doing I mean it it did I should say
it did right now because it's like we're
sold out right now and I'm taking a bit
of a Rebrand Hiatus with Dizzy right now
it's sold amazing and I know it still
what if it's on sale I'm just sober
right now I'm focusing on my weed brand
I want to see what I want to do with the
future of it you know what I mean I
maybe
it's my baby but at the same time I'm
I'm gonna be girl boss about it if it's
if I want to sell it and I want to do a
weed brand because I'm not drinking or
something you think you could but sell
the Dizzy you think there's people
interested
yeah that's I know there is
um but
yeah I mean it's sold out right now and
I'm I'm in the process of figuring
you're feeling that out yeah I'm feeling
that out and that's just honesty I could
make up a bunch of [__] for PR but
that's that's what's happening and I'm
content with that nothing bad has
happened and I made a lot of money and
people love it so it's like it's good to
put something on a hold right there
versus
in a point of turmoil or whatever
something that could just run itself you
put the wine in the can you present the
get you sell the can about it I guess
yeah but I
I think in order to get it to a sell
itself point it would have to be in a
lot more retail do you know what I mean
and that's that is it not in retail or
was it yes
um and so and we're we've gotten there
into the first steps of that but it
would be me promoting the [__] out of it
for a long like a full-time job yeah
yeah and I it's I care about it so much
it's one thing if it's something that's
just making you money and whatever but
dizzy has been something that has been
my merch and that I've said and that I
it's a big part of my brand and so I
would never want to just fine it's like
sorry I would never want to just like
[__] on it you know what I mean and then
now I'm about to be back in my
podcasting world with Jeff and with
Brooke and cancel this coming back my
podcast we run a little Hiatus that's
fun yeah we just we got a new production
company a new set all that type of stuff
so canceled 2.0 is about a b nice
obviously hopefully a great source of
income um yeah but also just I'm excited
to put my time and effort into that and
Jeff and I are finally starting our show
Friends with Benefits oh oh I like that
name yeah I like that name yeah it took
so long to get that legally clear and I
can finally say that is the name and
it's our show
um so Friends with Benefits is coming
very very soon versus me just co-hosting
Jeff FM you guys went and got it like
you guys did some kind of like there's a
lot yeah people a lot of people have
obviously it's a very common phrase in a
movie franchise or whatever the [__] so
you were just looking for conflicts or
something like people were gonna get mad
or were you trying to trademark it as a
pug it was trademarked so we had to kind
of get clearance but trademarked by
people
that
basically weren't using it or even if
they were a lot of people weren't really
seeing that's always the case it's so
annoying because you can people you
could trademark anything and they just
[__] sit on it for like 10 years I
thought it was going to be trademarked
by like is it Ashton Kutcher and or Mila
Kunis and Justin
Mila Kunis and [__] some what the
[__] what's your movie called friends
with benefits what when's your birthday
June 24th oh he's not I'm June I'm June
25th really every the internet says June
24 but it's wrong oh my God so now on my
birthday I can always expect you at
midnight and be like passing the test
right I love that you're such a cancer I
loved you I always liked having a June
birthday yeah it's so nice just the
beginning I absolutely love when the
birthday is here's a rocket going off in
the background I don't know this is you
oh my God yeah hey guys stupid coming at
you today with a new reaction video this
is the [__] that made me famous
just so stupid it's hard and I'm
recording I feel ashamed wanting it oh
yeah that was sorry guys just a little
explosion over here in Israel that was
that was actually a rocket blowing up
that's crazy yeah just so stupid
it's hard for me to talk about I feel
ashamed watching oh my God over here in
Israel yeah it was crazy yeah it was
insane and so did you eventually move to
Los Angeles because of
success the success oh we weren't really
successful when we moved we were little
we were starting but you were like we
always wanted to come back but when you
did you come here that we wanted to come
here yeah we couldn't tell it uh have
you lived all over L.A you guys we've
actually lived in Vegas for three weeks
because his parents were there
hi Connie do you know where in Vegas
[Music]
summerlin's money no they weren't we I
think we went to the Summerlin mall or
something like that yeah I don't know
well they lived somewhere where they
were like on the edge of the [__]
it's not like nowhere
yeah there's a couple different edges
out there
um we lived in New York one year yeah
we're so New York I could just see you
throughout at least you're aesthetic I
mean I love I love New York aesthetic
it's 450. oh my God yeah oh my God no I
could keep talking for a long time but I
have a laser hair appointment I have to
get my vagina lasered you guys oh you're
getting your vagina laser but
permanently removed hair removal no in
my whole vagina Barbie doll
um wait so what do you what part do you
remove like your hair it's hair removal
like you do the armpits and the vagina
and the legs and your hair just doesn't
grow right but like the whole thing you
laser it all off yeah okay you don't
have to shave interesting I'm trying to
cut any Corners in the shower man I'm
not trying to be in it now isn't it true
you need to do a bunch of lasers for it
to stick so have you already done it
down there um no today's my first vagina
really scared that scared wow here's
what the only thing I'm afraid of can I
just tell you I'm not afraid of the
laser at all it's that sometimes I go in
for [__] like this and it's
the person the girl that's doing stuff
like this whatever it is any procedure
lip filler [__] tattoo laser whatever
they're a fan they're they oh no that
I'm just a matter of fact
that is horrible wow
[__] and then she's like I love your
your stalker story
that is horrible
I think I would let it happen I think
that if I could sense it
would you stop it if she's like hey I'm
a fan you would you be like yeah no no
no no because a lot of times people
won't tell you until the end of it so
you kind of got it right the energy
oh my God yeah yeah like that that just
you know if I was like my armpit I don't
really care but I just don't want
someone like in my guts
that's such a personal thing like you
actually like because they're touching
right they're in there like fully in oh
yeah you know I never thought about this
until now yeah but when I go to the
fertility office like everybody there
knows me and they're just thinking about
your [__] wait I never only separated
in my head like there's the reception
everybody at the reception knows me yeah
but they know you then there's the the
other the other side and they give me
like ultrasounds like every week yeah
vaginal yeah and I only now occurred to
me that the girls were giving me the
ultrasound probably know me too
that's awesome only now I'm realizing
that you're unlocked like for real I
feel like first for whatever reason of
laser removal is worse because they're
like in there for sure because mine is
in the dark doctors got their degree
yeah what they're doing yeah and it's in
the dark report you it's professional
they're seeing it all the time and they
just put it in and then they don't have
to look real like for a long time in LA
is very equivalent to like a smoothie
shop you know what I mean like you can
go get your smoothies
a line that's the only thing that's
interesting to me but at the same time
oh my God
you might have my only fans or you've
heard me talk about my vagina at length
so I guess it's just like a fun it could
be a fun bonding experience what they
knew Lena from the show when she called
yeah they're like oh my God they said
I'm so sorry but like are you Lena well
I had no idea what I've been in there
what do you said anything to me
yeah I believe it she's referring to
that appointment but I don't know okay
so funny though dude that watch is so
fire yeah I mean am I good no I know yo
show off that watch a little bit that
thing is fire dude what is that um it's
actually I bought my best friend it
um really
so are you wearing it um those will be
like at home and he lives with me oh
okay um so he'll be at home and I'm like
I could take that for a spin today you
know is that real diamonds is that a
Rolex it's yes
it's the perks of I guess living with my
friends that I buy gifts for yeah like
you know yeah one sec Zach is a watch
connoisseur Zach are you able to get a
good look at this thing yeah I was
eyeing it when it came in actually it's
a Iced Out Day jokes beautiful watch
that's a good one it is it is a good
girl honestly this is one of the only
gifts where I bought it for him and I
was giving it to him and I was like why
the [__] wouldn't I just buy that for
myself there was not an ounce of me that
was like Yay you get this you don't even
wear that out like it's so expensive
looking it is scary I'm actually I'm
very when I do wear it which is
occasionally I try to let him have his
gift and not be awful
um well no I I guess I wear it but I
mean I will wear it for like daytime
things or fun things like today my
outfit was just very much giving Haynes
so I was like this could be fun to add
it yeah he will be like out on Melrose
like swinging it around and I'll be like
he's like I don't care I'll take a
bullet for it I'm like I would just get
you another watch like it's I'm not I
wouldn't do that because I already am so
like I get so scared of being robbed
um yeah for sure all right we do have to
go I could talk for another hour but uh
it was so much fun Tana thank you thank
you
so much fun best audience I love you H3
and I love it the audience Loves You by
the way the audience too thank you for
sure
yeah thanks for sharing really uh I'll
share anything with you intimate stuff
we were podcasting a couple times I
thoroughly and I I don't mean to sound
callous but I cannot wait for your
parents to die
you're right there with all of us I
think I don't know maybe not all of us
but you know I I'm not I don't feel
deathy about like I don't I can't wait
for anyone to die but like well I just
want to I just want to hear the story
I'll sit down with you alive or not
that's awesome I want to know right
thank you so much so so we've got the
only fans we've got the podcast coming
canceled is coming back we got the Jeff
podcast Friends with Benefits those are
those are what I want everyone to follow
oh happening yeah
and keep the lights on canceled and
Friends with Benefits are coming back
within the next month or so oh Link's in
the description to all of her stuff yes
thank you
thank you yay thank you Tana thanks for
watching everybody have a great weekend
we'll see you on Monday
yo Monday everybody Tata
[Music]
foreign